test
okay good morning to all
uh like to welcome our our guests in the
audience a lot of regulars there
and then for all the committee members
welcome and we have today
bills uh scheduled for executive session
all of them
we have uh attending the committee today
some people substituting in
and we'll go around here so we can
introduce um
matt simon over here he's in for ralph
today and and i understand that ralph is
doing fine
be back tomorrow
i had a telephone call with him and he's
you know
and coming around the table uh
we don't have any other subs on this
side
and
and you're going to have one sub coming
in david muse correct
for
marjorie porter
good
okay so uh we can go ahead and start and
and the discussion here uh i'd like to
recognize uh also one other thing that
we had
uh discussion regarding the side by side
for 1671 that should be sent to you you
should be getting that on your computers
uh
jen forrest mentioned that was sent out
this morning
so you should have that
and um we can have a little side by side
discussion on that a little later here
representative
so going on to the first bill
mr chairman i also have been doing
research on that question that i raised
on the agricultural bill where they want
to do a governmental nonprofit
and i had a meeting yesterday with a
lawyer who does this kind of thing he
says no no he looked at the bill and he
said no no you can't do this
but he's got a solution of how you can
do it and that is something similar to
what they do with the public defender's
office in the state and i've got
material coming on that that i will
share with the committee as well but i
just wanted to let you know that i have
done some research with lawyers who know
more than i do who have agreed that the
way the bill is presented you can't do
it
if nothing else he said it would open it
would wave the the um
immunity for the state so anything done
by that corporation the state could be
sued and would be fully liable
something i'm sure we have no intention
of doing so at any rate i just wanted to
let you know that i'm working on that
and that's coming as well
we don't have that schedule that that's
not in the docket
that's
which means i won't be here for it so if
it's not this week um because i leave
you know on the six so um but i i wanted
to bring it because i realized i won't
be here for it but i wanted to try and
get it before you guys
and let you know that i've done the work
on it and that the bill is going to need
an amendment to really be something
that's viable
legally viable along the way i keep
saying everybody i love the idea of the
agricultural education it's just the
structure that's the problem okay so we
will look at that
um
coming from an attorney speaking and
another attorney and every attorney i've
but i respect what you're saying
representative waltz and we will take
that and look at it when when we get
time to do that before
so i appreciate that comment are there
any is there any other information for
the committee today before we start
okay let's start with the first bill
this is a bill relative to requirements
for teacher certification and i look to
oh jeepers i'm going to hand the gavel
over
thank you mr chairman um
for the gavel uh i'll call on the yeah i
don't have that either call on the
chairman for a uh motion okay i'd like
i'll second that thank you
uh discussion
there
there are a number of reasons why i feel
that uh this bill is very you know it's
i don't it's just not doable
uh if we were to look at all the rules
and regulations that we have if you look
at 306
the
rules rules which we have and we have
rules the feds have regulations
uh the rules which we have are about 104
pages long as i recall in ed 306 which
is the minimum standards for
public school approval we have rules for
special ed we have rules for cte we have
rules for everything
and those rules may be applicable for a
superintendent to understand or even a a
building principle to read and
understand
however it's not necessary that you have
a first grade teacher understanding all
that i'm also concerned that
will
really slow down the process of seeking
emergency certification where you can't
find a particular teacher to fill a slot
where school districts and the
department of education presently have
an emergency process in which a person
can be given a one-year temporary
certification to get them on board and
we oftentimes do that in cases of of
like physical therapy occupational
therapies
et cetera you might have a speech
pathologist that doesn't have cs but
they have a four-year degree and they
can be working towards that and we can
work something out so the students can
receive service
there's
also just the issue of reciprocity
between one state and another state you
have reciprocity agreements here
throughout new england
and however this would just add in
another requirement that before you're
going to get certification in this state
you've got to jump through all these
hoops and and take a course our class
and and all these rules
and lastly there there's a cost to all
this uh who's going to be teaching this
particular class
and is it going to be doe is it going to
have to be
somebody else that's not identified so
with all that i would recommend that we
does the
seconder have any comments
uh
thank you mr vice chair uh no comments
other than i think the the chair will do
an excellent committee report on this
uh thank you any other comments from uh
uh i
see none so uh
thank you
this is house bill number
relative to requirements for teacher
certification
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is a yes
representative simon
yes
representative moffitt yes
representative soti yes
representative nelson yes
representative blue now yes
representative waltz yes
representative cornell
yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison yes
representative mullen yes
representative woodcock
representative muse
yes representative hall
yes
and i'm chairman ladd yes
so itl 18 to 0.
great um mr chairman the gavel is back
to you okay i'm going to go get the
gavel
yes
when i have um emails
that say that people were going to be
absent or who the subs are do they go
with the clerk stuff or they just
um i i don't know if they need to go
with the clerk no that stuff is just for
implement that doesn't okay you don't
okay
okay we're ready to go ahead and
deal with the executing hb 10
90 relative to teaching on
discrimination in the public schools i
look to represent lakas for a motion
okay and we have a set we have a motion
made by representing lycus and second by
representing nelson
discussion representative leicas
we're going to be hearing a lot
having to do with rsa 19340
and as well as
the other section 130 what three
at any rate the other section
um
so i want to get some things clear since
we're going to keep
talking about this for quite a few bills
i'm still trying to understand
what the objections are so i'm going to
go through this
sort of line by line and when you guys
say that you have an objection please
let me know so that i know oh we object
number one
no pupil in any public school in this
state shall be taught that one sexual
orientation is inherently superior to
people of another sexual orientation
anybody have a problem with that
is it clear
so mr chair yeah um i just want to um
make it clear that that
we we're not responsible for uh having
to indicate
uh whether
to representative likus's questions
whether we have a problem with it if she
doesn't have a problem with those
statements that's up to her to state but
i don't think we need to be responsive
line by line and if we do not respond i
don't think that's an indication that we
don't have a problem with what she's
reading certainly people are free to
respond but but no response doesn't mean
that we're okay i would just want to
make that abundantly clear i think
you've made your point very clear
and that nobody has to respond on this
committee to another person if you
desire not to
go and on the other hand
that leaves me free to assume that you
agree
no pupil
leaves me free
it may not leave the rest of the
committee free well we're telling you we
don't consent that okay that's fine you
don't consent
no pupil in any public school in this
state shall be taught that an individual
by virtue of their sexual orientation is
inherently racist sexist or oppressive
whether consciously or unconsciously
no people in any public school mr
chairman yes representative could i ask
what representative flakis is reading
because i have the law as currently
written in front of me
and and i'm not
i don't know what you what you're
reading from representing that's fair
instead of say i went and instead of
saying taught instructed inculcated or
compelled to express belief in or
support for any one or more of the
following i just picked the first word
taught okay to make it easier because
that's what you do when you have a long
list
because then we'll go back and look at
those other words and see if it's
instructed inculcated or compelled
etcetera that is objectionable i'm
trying to make it clear
what you need to do is that
this is a
a bill which we're addressing and you've
indicated that you've made a motion to
itl the bill
with that uh you would give a rationale
of why you're making that particular
motion well i mean you can you can give
your research to and then you can
counter that yourself
okay well may i follow up yes
representative mullen
i'm looking at the law and the first
indicator is one's age
so yeah so
what what i
if in fact we're not going to get that
this back and forth represent like us
you have the floor to
support your your motion uh if there are
questions that need to be answered uh
they can be done after you
you know
after it goes to another person to have
to be recognized by the chair we can't
go back and forth like this thank you i
appreciate that yes
i don't wish to be
to go through
the
statute piece by piece by piece i don't
i feel patronized in some way
that um
that i'm part of a class now
that um is learning about this law
that's not that's not what we're doing
here today we are voting up or down on
these
these uh bills and the bill
uh
representative lakers has has said her
um you know support for this bill or her
support for the itl i'm sorry
and i think that
you know you've made it clear but i i
really object
to going through
represent like us would you go ahead
please proceed thank you thank you i
we keep saying we're going to repeal
this i want to make it clear what we're
repealing that's why we're going through
it because this is what i object to i
don't understand why we're repealing
this and that's why i'm going through
the bill
the bill says no pupil in any public
school in the state shall be taught that
an individual should be discriminated
against or receive adverse treatment
solely or partly because of their sexual
orientation
no pupil or in in any public school in
the state shall be taught that people of
one sexual orientation cannot treat
others without regard to sexual
orientation yes
i object i i don't know how more to
object to this than to get up and leave
i find this totally patronizing
to be
read the bill if
i would not try to read a bill
reading the law actually reading the law
yes um
to say you know what's objectionable in
here obviously you don't find anything
objectionable in it
others do
and that's why we vote on a bill rather
than
go through law piece by piece by piece i
i just i don't know how to object any
stronger we we have read read the law
represent like us what you need to do
right now is to explain why you are
offering this particular position
of itl
okay number one all of those in section
one i i
think we should all be supporting
i'm trying to find out because we're
my understanding with an exec session is
that we are supposed to be discussing
not just oh we're voting this way
because of this we're voting this way
because of this end of statement vote go
i thought we were supposed to discuss
this is a bill this is a piece of law
that bill after bill is trying to repeal
and so the question is why are we
repealing this and so
why i am trying to understand what the
objection to this piece of law is
that was why i was going through
each section and say okay so i can if
since you have read it and you have it
and you know what it is
what are the objections to section two
how's that
then i'm not reading it and that can be
answered if it's so if people so desire
when you give the floor up another
opportunity to speak
mr chairman i would be willing to
respond on a more general basis to
representative leakers i'm certainly not
going to go section by section
but what she's looking for is why people
object and i would address that if she's
so interested
we're going through the parliamentary
process right now where the maker of the
motion has an opportunity to explain why
the motion was put forth the second has
the same opportunity to do that
then when we get into the debating on
that then that's what follows
and that's the process we saw if there
are questions let's get this motion you
know put forth we have it put forth but
have the maker and then the second
explain why they're you know of that
opinion or that position
and then we can get into the questioning
back and forth through our discussion
okay thank you
i will do that um
i keep reading this i i do not
understand
what the problem is
i am itling it because i don't want to
get rid of this piece of law i think it
is a good piece of law and i am quite
happy to listen to people who will point
out specifically
what it is that they object to and why
because
it's all based on those first four lines
that i read yes i did not read every
single
age sex gender identity sexual
orientation race creed color marital
status etc
because why by the time you put all
those words in you can't understand what
it says so the way you read something
like that is you pick one of the words
and use that one
and and when you have something that
with the same thing and then there's a
list you put the same thing in front of
it so i wanted to make it very clear
what it is
that we're talking about because we're
going to be talking about it all day and
i wanted to make it very clear what it
was
because i hear all kinds of arguments
about what these things say and i wanted
to make it clear what it says because i
keep hearing that it says things that it
doesn't say
and so i just wanted everybody to hear
exactly what it does say
but
i won't patronize you and read it that
way thank you thank you very much
representative nelson do you ha as maker
of the second do you have any discussion
okay it's open to the full committee now
for discussion representative waltz
thank you mr chairman
um
i'm going to direct this to
representative lakers so i'm sure the
whole committee is appropriate for the
whole committee what you don't
understand and what is puzzling to you
is why
you don't see where any one of these
individual issues it's not the
individual issue it's the summation of
them it's a chilling this bill has been
proposed in states around the country
and if you read the news like i do
nationally not just in new hampshire but
nationally these bills are chilling the
teaching of history in this country
teachers are afraid to go anywhere near
these topics because they're afraid
they're going to be accused of violating
the law
so there are huge gaps now in what our
children are being taught because
teachers are scared to address
touchy subject matters and these are
difficult subject narrators but they're
important the history of racial
discrimination in our country is a
crucial part of our history we've fought
a war over it but teachers are afraid to
go there teaching about it in any way
shape or form they're afraid to teach
about the civil rights movement a huge
part of our history
this is a law that chills the ability of
teachers to teach it's a law that
deprives our children thereby depriving
our children of an appropriate
understanding of history that is why
people object to it so you're right if
you pick it apart one at a time word by
word it's hard to find a specific thing
that somebody objects to but when you
look at it in its entirety as one must
with any law
it is a law that chills teaching the
truth
and that's why it's problematic
representative
see
representative tanner
thank you it's it's hard to get
recognized over here in the corner
um well especially when represent luna
has his head right in front that's right
right that's right i gotta go like this
right
so um
i just want to say that this bill is the
start of censorship in schools and we
know that because we see it as
representative walt says across the
united states but it's happening in in
new hampshire as well
censorship has started it first it's
starting with civil rights
and history of the civil war
and history of the united states but
it's extended far beyond that in fact in
the first section you read
we have florida who is taking gay out of
the school uh any talk of of any
um sexual orientation
it's uh we heard in even testimony in
here uh people see it as transgenderism
getting transgenderism out of the school
we've heard of books being burned
and attacking schools i went to a school
board meeting the other day
and at that school board meeting
the chair the uh assistant
superintendent talked about how
uh some vigilante because that's the
other part of this bill is it sparks
vigilantism and has a 500 reward for for
finding out about teachers and evidently
somebody in his district
wanted that 500
because they had called and said that
they had seen on this teacher's facebook
and uh i just want to remind everybody
that they're trolling facebook
that she had joined a
a group of um teachers that were talking
uh about
this particular law and about the the
ramifications and the and the guide
rails for it
and because of that this person this
citizen this parent
wanted this teacher investigated
and and spelled out how she wanted this
teacher investigated wanted the
superintendent to go into the classroom
wanted to confiscate all the curriculum
that this teacher was teaching
wanted to have
the teacher brought up before the school
board
and the assistant superintendent said
you know this is one of our best
teachers
and
he said what a waste of my time
she's an excellent teacher
she teaches the truth
she didn't do anything objectionable
this person had never been in her class
that
the student her child had long ago
graduated from the school it was simply
something that she heard on the radio
the television
through
certain um
apps or uh
facebook herself facebook pages yourself
this is what this bill does
or this law does and this bill seeks to
reverse that
what is being taught at schools and how
it's being taught
is really a local issue it's
superintendents
and um i think our schools uh
address issues when they come up um just
like this one was a just but as this
assistant superintendent said
with everything going on covet
everything that they've gone through
what a waste of time
thank you
further discussion
representatives
our law isn't the same as florida or the
rest of them there are only four
sections
i mean four lines they're very clear
what they are that's why i had wanted to
read the four things they're very clear
and
we can't
get rid of laws because people spread
misinformation about them what a way to
get rid of any law we want to get rid of
just get out and spread misinformation
and then people will say
i can't do anything with that because of
you know misinformation that's out there
it's the spreading of misinformation
that has teachers terrified that has
that has teachers saying i can't teach
anything that has the chilling effect
and the appropriate response is not to
say well let's take care of the get
let's get rid of this law because
there's all this misinformation the
correct response is to say let's get the
proper information out there because i
think if you read those first things the
things that they say they're not
supposed to be teaching
nobody in here will object i didn't
expect anybody to object to any of them
because they're not objectionable
they're things that we've all been
arguing and fighting for for years
all these things this
anti-discrimination we don't want these
kids discriminated against
and that's what it's about keeping the
kids from being discriminated against
and it's very clear but some people
apparently do want to discriminate and
therefore they're spreading
misinformation and everybody's reacting
to the misinformation so rather than
getting rid of the law
we it's a good law
it's it's it's just saying don't do
these things that we've been saying
don't do
we should get that information out there
we should get the truth out there and
say no this law doesn't say you can't
teach about racism or any of that other
stuff it says you can't say one race is
better than another race
it says you can't teach that somebody
should be discriminated against based on
their race
that's nothing just that we don't none
of you want teachers doing that right
that's what you've been saying for years
you don't want teachers doing that
that's all this is sure i've got it i've
got to object to words being put in our
mouths oh okay expectations being being
said of what we should be voting for and
what we should be supporting i think
this is just outrageous
and um and and and and a very extreme uh
an extreme position and and just not a
not fruitful debate representative
mullen
thank you mr chair um i i'm gonna
present perhaps a little different point
of view
i think teachers are chilled by the
prohibition of the free exchange of
ideas in their classroom
not
because somehow or another they don't
want to protect the protected classes
so i think that the prohibition against
free exchange of ideas is in fact
chilling i also think that
we're forgetting that this law also
provides for
civil action against teachers schools
school districts
we're also forgetting that it's a very
vague law
and that a violation by a teacher of a
law that is very vague could result in
being found guilty of of uh
crimes against the teacher code of
conduct
so i think this goes way beyond whether
or not we are uh in fact protecting the
protected classes
because once we move beyond that
language
i think the intent becomes clear
that this
that this is set up to be a legalistic
issue
further discussion representative uh
waltz
thank you
you know
what has happened with this is
and all you only have to read our emails
to see it people writing to us all the
time say i don't want critical race
theory taught in the schools the words
critical race theory are not in this law
but they have interpreted this law to be
critical race theory the fact of the
matter is most of them have no idea what
critical race theory is and they have
twisted it into something it's not and
they're going after teachers saying
you're teaching critical race theory
when one they're not to the
the person making the allegation doesn't
understand what critical race theory is
this is mccarthyism all over again this
is no different than what mccarthy did
in the 50s where you put stuff out there
you scare people they're afraid to talk
and then they are chilled so that they
won't go there this is wrong and if we
understand history we know that we
should not be doing this again
thank you representative cordelli
thank you
first i would point everybody to 193 40
roman 2 which says nothing in this
section shall be construed to prohibit
discussing as part of a larger course of
academic instruction the historical
existence of ideas and subjects
identified in this section
i think that that's
pretty clear
i i see nowhere is there any prohibition
of the free exchange of id ideas
and in terms of mccarthyism
if you look at the department of justice
website
there is a link
to a complaint form to submit uh
complaints
about parents
so uh you know
i i think that's chilling
and it started with the department of
education the us department of education
to the national school boards
association to the department of justice
um it was a whole pre-arranged um
motion that
got the doj and fbi involved
um to tracking parents so if you want to
talk about chilling
to me that is chilling
and i see nothing in here
that
should
present a chilling effect on the
teaching of of slavery or
the civil war or anything else um it's
extend
what's in 354 our human rights
commission
to prevent any
inculcation or compelling of students to
express one belief
in
in a classroom or outside a classroom
so i i am totally supportive of the uh
the ital itl motion further discussion
representative
tanner
thank you mr chair
you know we have a
law on the books that allows a parent to
come into the school
and object to any material and actually
provide
alternative
education for it as a former health
teacher
you can bet that over the 35 years that
i taught we had several people that came
in and had objections and each time that
parent came in with objections
uh we dealt with it uh the student was
given alternative uh course of of study
and we went on and everybody seemed very
satisfied with that um if that
law was working and i feel from personal
experience it was working very well for
both parents
who wanted certain
topics to be taught at home and not in
the school that's great
they were able to do that
then why on earth
did we need
to have a bill like this
offered five hundred dollars
to
report a teacher
and that teacher as representative
mullin said one of the chilling effects
is just like this teacher at kearsarge
was that
she could have lost her license
her credential
that's her livelihood
spent thousands of dollars on education
to get there
has worked very hard
and put in her time and loyalty and
teachers go above and beyond
and yet something like this
could be drummed up
and that teacher loses their license i
to say it doesn't have a chilling effect
um is failing to see reality i think
thank you
further discussion representative luna
thank you very much mr chair yeah i i
mean i think too to
to fail to see that the existing law
doesn't have a chilling effect really
ignores i think a lot of the testimony
that that we've heard in this committee
that has come across in other committees
and that has um
been uh been published um in newspapers
and and
media across the state
once in particular i can think of is is
um is from
uh
the um the rudman center at unh law
where where specifically the law was
cited is having a a chilling effect on
teachers and and very much i think you
know corresponds to what we've heard in
this committee where quote the law's
broad use of the word teach dissuades
teachers from presenting material as a
jumping off point for discussion unless
they be accused of indoctrinating
students simply because they expose them
to uh to one author's thesis
we've got
other testimony
because quote because of the vague
language and stiff penalties some
educators will inevitably avoid
important topics concerning race and
gender because they fear being the
subject of a complaint or a lawsuit from
an angry parent or student who does not
like what is uh in their curriculum
and um
and you know i'm not i you know like i
could i could go on and say you know
what the what why
these discussions are important but i
don't even think you have to i can i can
i think just just the chilling effect
alone
is is just so abhorrent to what we
consider to be
public you know public education public
schools and uh
and um
and the ability for for teachers
to be able to address uh complaints
either directly with parents directly
with students or or directly with their
school boards
and um and
you know
we've we've heard this nearly
universally it's it's fun for all of us
to sort of like pretend like
like you know we're the we're the
end-all when it comes to understanding
these situations but i think taking the
information and relying on the
information that we hear from from
experts and in this case a really
diverse set of experts in the field that
call this law chilling
and uh and advocate for its repeal
finally i'd i'd say
another expert and this is actually from
a from a law firm and there's a number
of law firms that have weighed in on
this
is is you know in law firms a lot of law
firms i think like it when um when you
know um when the right of
private action opens up and can provide
um
business for this for them you know
whether it's suing teachers or some
school districts all that translating
into higher property taxes but uh but
this law firm says despite its brevity
or perhaps because of it it creates a
legal minefield for new hampshire public
school teachers and school
administrators and i think that extends
right to uh right to property taxpayers
as well that are going to have to pay
the the funds to defend schools from uh
from these cases so i think what the
bill that we're looking at here
not only not only puts teachers back
into the into the mode of teaching but
uh but protects property taxpayers from
frivolous lawsuits
further discussion representative
woodcock
thank you mr chairman um
i appreciate the representative
cordelie's comments on the
apparent issue the parent concern and
that does sound chilling but it's not
applicable to this particular bill
what i find chilling in this is as a
former high school social science
teacher i was reflecting upon that young
woman who was in here about
well today's on the 9th of february
talking about the limitations to put on
this her ap class
and her potential teaching
we know that when we allow good teachers
to teach
inquisitive
socratic
thought-provoking dialogues
students
now become interested involved have a
chance to dialogue themselves and the
whole process of education takes off and
grows and grows those are the types of
youngsters and the types of dialogues we
want in schools so the children come out
as young leaders young adults and move
on to become questioning
leaders in our country and making
decisions for the betterment of the
people
but when we restrict the information we
allow them to have or we
provide a law that makes it
uncomfortable
for teachers to provide that type of
instruction or limits in their mind
because of possible litigation that type
of instruction we've done a real
disservice to the base public education
process all the way up from the time we
try to create critical thinking in our
kids
critical thinking skills we need to have
that dialogue we can't do it on a very
washed out pastel
fake form of history
so i suggest that this is a huge
impact on public education
as it is on discrimination and
discrimination issues
thank you mr chairman
thank you uh representative litchfield
did you have your hand up
i did
thank you
so i i wanted to start by saying that i
understand where you're all coming from
because
that's my platform is i don't agree with
censorship so i absolutely agree 100
with where you're coming from and i can
understand why the teachers would feel
paralyzed when they're teaching simply
because
i feel it even from the moment i won my
state legislator election because even
right now as i speak and the same with
you right we all know
everything that we're saying on camera
they're going to use those snippets for
or against us
my concern is within the classrooms no
matter what we're talking about when it
comes to even deij or any of this sort
of thing
it just needs to be balanced so we're
talking about what the teachers are
sharing for books right my concern is
if they want to share one type of book
that people may be uncomfortable with we
need to have that balance
and what i'd like to do if this is
allowed is just toss a question to rep
lacus and i just want to get a better
understanding for there's a reason why
this law came to be in the first place
last year it didn't come out of the blue
there's a reason for it what is the
reason for it is is that okay to do or i
could toss it to anybody in the room yes
that there's no problem with that what's
the basis for the law sure
because we have seen
teachers
and administrators
teaching things that basically says that
one race is inherently better than
another race
these are some things that
i mean and that's specifically in here
it doesn't say you can't talk about race
you can't talk about all the bad things
that have happened all the racism it
says you can't teach that one race is
better than another and that's why the
words are very specific
not general but very specific there are
four specific items
and that's one of them and it's because
and i will say i know this is happening
a girl came home i happened to be
visiting her mom she was a friend of my
daughters and my daughter was out
and she came home in tears now she has a
biracial family right her mom is very
blonde
her dad is very black
and she happens to be the lightest of
the siblings and she came home in tears
because she was taught that because she
was white she was inherently racist
and she's a teenage kid right an
adolescent and she knows that being
racist is being evil and bad i mean
that's how it gets translated right
so she came home in tears now her
siblings are darker than her they're not
racist but because she happened to be
born lighter than her siblings she was
racist in other words she was evil
and this is a teenage girl who's already
having to deal with all those
self-image things that teenage girls are
having to deal with that is being taught
and that is why
these specific things were put in here
and they are four very specific things
because these are the things that people
were coming up against and that's why
further discussion
representative nelson did you have your
hand up for
representative moffat
thank you miss chair
um like represent woodcock i also is a
history social studies teacher public
schools parochial schools
uh mccarthyism
is
was and is uh it's in the dictionary now
it involves alarmist
scare tactics emotionalizing issues and
i am hearing
alarmist scare tactics emotionalized
issues on on this bill and on the
current law
to represent litchfield's point hb 54
originally came about because of genuine
documented concerns about proselytation
in the classroom there are plenty of
examples representative letters just
gave one
so to your question there are legitimate
reasons why that hb 54 came about now
hb54 did not become lie as it came to
to uh
the legislature didn't come to this
committee
the what's in law now is
words that are very
very benign and as representative
cordelli said
the law specifically protects
educators who want to have critical
thinking happen and have back and forth
happen
um
i think representative while somebody
mentioned the mail that we get the
emails in this we get a ton of them and
message after message after message is
reversed
banned concepts divisive concepts
that that is not in law
and you know as a teacher i want to
correct these emails and send it back to
people and say you're using words that
are not in law
so i and as a again as a history teacher
i would not be at all threatened by this
if i do my job and do it right um and
don't proselytize what there's nothing
to worry about in terms of these scare
tactics i would venture to wager i
do make best from time about a year from
now there's not a single bounty that
will be collected i'll bet i'd be
surprised if there were any prosecutions
what this existing statute does is it
addresses legitimate real concerns and
it became law through the civics process
i don't have a problem with the current
law and so therefore i support the itl
motion
further discussion representative tanner
and allison
um i don't think it came through the
regular civics process
and uh that's another part of the
problem stakeholders weren't involved uh
there wasn't a lot of discussion it was
actually i think put in hb2 if i'm
correct
representative ellison uh thank you mr
i asked the maker of this motion in a
prior session if she could give me
examples of that
from new hampshire schools that the law
was supposed to address she has yet to
respond other than the one example she
just gave me
and i would also
[Music]
question
the statement that was just made that
there are plenty of examples in new
hampshire schools where
things have taken place that the
original law addresses
so i i think we're dealing with uh
some conjecture here
and some wishful thinking on the part of
the people who were involved in this
representative nelson
thank you mr chairman i don't me don't
know whose side this will be on
but i
sat in on a classroom as a teacher in
the eighth grade
and i had to keep my mouth checked
because i was the guest not a guest but
an observer and this particular young
lady new teacher was talking about world
war ii
and japan and apologize for us bombing
japan with the atomic bomb now she never
gave the other side of this
she never said how many hundred thousand
american troops would have been killed
she never mentioned any of that
that's all she said all i could think of
is the kids leaving that classroom and
going home to the grandparents whoever
were alive back then and what they must
have thought when they spewed this out
and i was very concerned and i went to
her at the end of the class because it
was inappropriate for me to interrupt
and i said where did you get this from
she said my college teacher
that was it so these kids have something
in their mind at least if they could
have been justified to say this side and
this side i would have been happy
but
anyway that's just a frustration
representative woodcock
thank you i just i just wanted to
uh thank you uh
mr representative nelson i would agree
that would be
a shame that all the information was put
out there but my point is that i would
also agree with representative tanner
when president lynchial asked a question
and the the response to the question
is it never came through this committee
it wasn't part of the civics process it
came on the back of a budget bill where
dialogue was not allowed had dialogue
been allowed we may not be here
discussing this today
so that's not a real civic process
that's not democracy by any means um so
that's that's why we're here to look at
this bill
thank you
further discussion from the committee
representative moffat famous real quick
the legislative process as we all know
uh
allowed for
a version of five five five four four to
go for it had a full hearing uh it was
uh determining which committee heard it
was not this committee perhaps it should
have been this committee but it was a
long extended emotional series of
a bunch of testimony on 544 which was
changed in response to the testimony and
yes it wasn't part of hb2 or sb the
budget so it is a legitimate part of law
it was
law making is like sausage making but
the legislative process was legitimate
and um so that i just wanted to say that
that's probably why sausage is unhealthy
i didn't give name specific school names
because sometimes i have problems
recalling names and didn't want to
accidentally say the wrong name
laconia dover
and we had testimony from a lady who
came in and had evidence on lots of
other schools the superintendents are
actually teaching
actual crt
in the in the
in-service teacher training days and
pushing it and i do have copies of
slides that are used and they start out
with things like
the way to talk to a white kid about
privilege
i can email you those slides if you want
to see them i was going to copy them off
and present them when i do present when
we do hear that bill but if you want to
know about it beforehand yes there is
evidence and yes we have the slides
thank you
representative waltz
representative lancaster you just made
my point because you said
superintendents are teaching actual
critical race theory and i suspect you
don't know what actual critical race
theory is because if you talk to an
academic at a university
actual critical race theories just says
that some of our institutions
are inherently
racially biased and that's true we know
that's some of that about policing some
of our institutions over time have had
some inherent bias embedded in them and
the supreme court and others have and
congress and state legislators have
passed laws to try and counter that bias
critical race theory does not teach that
one race is better than another it talks
about institutions that's what true
critical race theory is
i don't think you believe
that that that is what's being taught in
our schools that there are institutional
issues so what i'm suggesting is your
use of the terms critical race theory is
what's out there in the parlance and
it's the misunderstanding of what true
critical race theory is and about how
there have been institutional issues in
this country that needed to be addressed
in laws and in case law
you know i agree that we should not be
teaching one race is better than another
that is not critical race theory if you
go ahead and yes
i know that's why i didn't bring that up
here
because this is not about critical race
theory i know that i was addressing the
fact that he went back to 1255 and said
that i didn't come up with any instances
and i was giving instances for 1255
and according to these slides and these
people they are claiming its critical
race theory
i've heard lots of different things what
critical race theory means
all i'm saying is they are claiming it
no they're not teaching these things
this does not have to do with critical
race theory
okay i know that and that's why it
doesn't say critical race theory
anywhere in here
but i was responding he was talking
about i was talking about indoctrination
and
teaching a specific theory or ideology
or idea
and so that was the examples i was
giving for that i was responding to his
question about specifics not about this
bill at all that was about a totally
different bill
and i was responding to the fact you
said specifically that superintendents
and others are teaching critical race
theory in our schools when you said that
that's what i felt the need to respond
to because i don't believe that's true
well they believe that's true because
that's what they called it and so all
i'm saying is they're teaching what they
believe is critical race theory which is
um at any rate further discussion
yes representative simon
thank you mr chair um always a little
bit hesitant to jump into a conversation
when you're not a part of the actual
committee where people have been
discussing this at length but
um for whatever it's worth i have
personal experience with this particular
issue both of my children
attended a school
where these topics were discussed um
and in a sense it is a manifestation of
critical race theory even if it's not
critical race theory that's being taught
and i think this law in particular looks
to address um the idea that critical
race theory would be manifested in our
school system and what i mean by that is
is levied against children
to tell them things about themselves
that are untrue
and the child has to deal with the
institutional power coming down upon
themselves it's not one child saying
something to another child it's going
into
an auditorium where something is being
presented by the official capacity of
the institution where they're made to
fill out surveys in which they're asked
what their race is what their
socioeconomic status is what their
sexuality is and my daughter came home
in tears the first day saying the only
thing i've got for me is i'm a is i'm a
girl otherwise i'm the worst human being
on the world
and i watched as relationships that she
had with her friends who were majority
people of color
disintegrated over her time in that
school so the point that after
graduation one of her friends contacted
her a little bit later and said i'm
sorry
i had no idea how bad it had really
gotten until i got away for a little bit
it took
two years
for my daughter to decompress from that
whole
situation
it happens
it is the institutional power behind it
that matters
that is a manifestation of critical race
theory even if it's not what's
technically being taught
and uh i think that's what this law
seeks to address
and i do take issue i don't want a
chilling effect on teachers i don't
but when the teachers are using the
institutional power to go after children
that i object to and that does happen
and i've experienced it firsthand and
i've been in that battle two years
against teachers who are are are highly
educated teachers and and to be honest
with you not even i wouldn't even
consider them to be bad people they're
good people i'm i was friends with them
they're
and they're educated people you know
harvard grads and things of this nature
but there's there are ideas
there are ideas that we need to handle
with care when the institutional power
is behind them because children don't
have the power to stand up to that
institutional power
and to me that would be the concern so
once again for what it's worth not an
official member of this committee
but that that has been my personal
experience when it comes to these
particular topics so thank you for the
opportunities thank you very much
representative simon representative
julius
yeah frankly i was thinking about this
law er the way it is written
and i feel that
if back in the 1920s
germany had had a law like this
like the uh
the other representative i am a guest
in this committee
but one of the things that struck me
about this particular law uh all the way
along
is the chilling effect that it does have
on teachers and the chilling effect that
it has on teaching kids things that they
really do need to know
taking history courses
where literally the the only black
person we learned about in detail was
booker washington
if you grew up in the 60s there were a
lot of people who thought martin luther
king was a criminal
um
we weren't taught about things like
reconstruction we weren't taught about
things like jim crow laws
and these are things that we are not
individually responsible for
we were not personally involved in these
things but what we have the opportunity
to do through education
is to teach our kids
why these things happened
what were the circumstances that led
to some of these terrible things and
some of these terrible laws happening
and what are some of the things that we
can do in the future
to prevent those things from happening
again
and especially in a state
new hampshire the last time i i looked
at demographic census we're 90 white
and i think it's more incumbent on
states like ours
where we do have
a significant
majority of one particular racial
composition
to understand what people in the other
racial compositions have actually gone
through
and some of the struggles that they've
seen in our society is they try to
become equal
i'm in the criminal justice and public
safety committee and one of the things
that we talk about all the time
is systemic racism
we have programs at the police standards
and training academy
that actually
try to
to try to deal that that try to make
officers aware of things like that these
are not things that are illusions
these are things that that actually
exist
and they're things that we have an
opportunity to overcome
but
laws like this
just make things so much more difficult
because they stifle
conversations that really that really
need to be had and i think they're not
just conversations that
that students need to have with teachers
but they're conversations that parents
need to have with their kids
um i was fortunate because i grew up in
a household where my parents were
willing to have those conversations with
everything that was going on in the 60s
with martin luther king being shot with
malcolm malcolm x being shot with the
demonstrations on tv every single night
from places from places down south and i
mean
try to understand what that was like i
think a lot of us sort of live through
it and sometimes i think we forget what
it was like to kind of go through those
times as a child where you're trying to
understand things
so we're in a position now where where
we have on some of these issues
we do have the perspective of time
and these are things that do need to be
in our curriculum and sometimes teachers
are going to raise them in ways that
make them uncomfortable
but i don't think it means we need to be
prosecuting teachers
we heard another bill
where teachers
we have a teacher a hiring crisis and
staffing crisis in this state anyway
and this bill
is not
making this any better it's not making
new hampshire a more attractive place to
teach
and
thank you very much representative muse
are there further
any further discussion from the
committee
representative simon sorry debate of the
debate of the two people who aren't
actually on the committee and very well
spoken
to do so go for it both of you it was it
was all very well said and and i agree
with you on so many of your points and
obviously the heart at which you're
coming at this uh what i would what i
would express is in my experience with
some of this particular material
for example on martin luther king day
martin luther king had the famous
statement he wants to see a world in
which people are judged on the contact
content of their character not on the
color of their skin but on martin luther
king day instead of teaching that to the
children they broke them off into racial
affinity groups
and segregated them from each other so
they could have race specific
conversations
and and i don't i don't see how that
achieves the goals the lofty goals to
which you would you would want to see us
achieve
um
there there are things about that and
and maybe maybe this is where the deeper
discussion needs to happen maybe there's
there is confusion as to what's actually
happening
and what that actually produces out into
society
my experience with this genuinely
was that it increased racism it
increased animosity it didn't it didn't
solve anything
um
it only exacerbated it and made it worse
where there wasn't any before where
children got along very well and
supported one another and
served with one another and learned with
one another and discussed with one
another they stopped talking
because some were taught that they were
oppressed and some thought that they
were oppressors
and and it just broke everything apart
so so maybe some clarification needs to
happen in the language maybe some some
deeper study needs to to happen but but
to say that that that's not happening
i know that it is i and i've experienced
it so um once again for what it's worth
i agree with your sentiments but i think
there there are things that are
happening that would actually undermine
uh undermine that and i think that
that's what this law from my perspective
this law is seeking to address simply
that i can't walk up to you and say
because you're white
you're racist
you're bad you need to get out of the
way
um
and and that that teaching is although
not
not it doesn't encompass critical race
theory it is a part of uh the general
critical race theory um spectrum of of
thought
and that would be the systemic nature of
it um so once again
it's it's difficult being in the
committee and listening because i feel
like valid things are being said on both
but but not necessarily i don't feel
like the conversation has necessarily
hit at all of the essential truths so
that's all thank you
any further discussion representative
cordelli
uh thank you um
just point out that a lot of this
discussion has been about um subject of
race but the law
goes
well beyond that in terms of other
classes
so that
there should be no
instruction inculcation that
one religion is better than the other
that is superior to the other um you
know would would we want anyone to walk
up to
uh
someone coming out of a synagogue and
said uh
you know
jews or such and such or um
a parish and say catholics are such and
such uh no that's what that's what this
bill is trying to um address it's not
just race
um it's um religion um
family status
whole bunch of issues that um i think
that
you know we need to be careful in
addressing and and not promoting the
idea that one is better than the other
um thank you
yes representative mullen
thank you mr chair you know what i'm
having a hard time wrapping my head
around
the fact that the legislative body
passed a law last year
that protected religious and private
schools from anyone being able to
question
their ideology their mission their uh
credos or
i'm having a hard time
sort of
i don't know putting it into a
perspective where
i can justify that we're going to
censor public school teachers but if you
teach in a private or a religious school
then
you don't have to
this law doesn't apply to you
so i
don't know i mean i i offer it as a
commentary more than more than a
question
because it just seems ironic to me that
this legislature passed a law to protect
private and religious schools and this
seems antithetical to that in public
schools
representative mullen i i'd like to try
to respond a little bit to that
we have religious exemptions
in numerous areas of legislation
i.e medications
and in that
i agree with you i believe the way that
is written it is discriminatory
against the person who has no religion
but has a right of conscience
a right of belief
and your religion is your belief
my religion might be that it's not
religious belief it's my conscience and
my principles that i guide myself by and
that's my right of conscience and that's
in inherent to me
so
you know i believe that we try to wrap a
lot of this up in some form of
legislation i don't think we always do a
great job of that
so that's my response that that there's
representative tanner
i think
the discussion that we've had for almost
over an hour now
really indicates that this bill should
go to interim study
um i think
it would be good to uh have a robust
discussion about the bill
um and
to have some public airing um
public testimony so i would i would say
that i plan to vote against
the itl and
i would say that an interim study might
be offered thank you
any further discussion
yes ref san luno sure thanks very much
mr chair
and
excuse me
you know just just real
real real simply uh you know i i don't i
don't see that there's any moral high
ground in support of the uh the existing
law
either in the words that uh that are in
statute now or how that uh that statute
was uh was arrived at i think the
existing law is quite simply about
censorship in schools with super high
stake penalties for um
for teachers and
and
exposes school districts to um
frivolous um lost lawsuits and having to
defend those so so
honestly i think the repeal language
makes a lot of sense i'm certainly going
to oppose the itl and i would support an
interim study but i'd also support an
otp on this thank you
thank you very much further discussion
from the committee
not seeing any madam clerk would you
please call the roll
yes thank you
this is relative to house bill 1090
relative to teaching on discrimination
in the public schools the motion on the
table is itl
representative cordelli
yes
representative litchfield is a yes
representative simon yes representative
lakis
yes representative moffitt yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford
yes representative
yes representative nelson yes
representative luno no
representative waltz no
representative cornell no
president of tanner no
representative ellison no representative
mullen no
representative woodcock
i'm sarah
no
and represent paul no
chairman ladd yes
thank you very much uh we will now
proceed into
minority
yeah i'm sure there'll be a minority
blurb uh
um
represent luna let me know who's going
representative mullen will be doing that
and
the minority motion will be ought to
pass
okay uh we'll move on to the next bill
does everybody have a copy of it
okay
1576 is an act repealing the law
relative to certain discrimination in
represent lakers do you have a motion
i move itl
is there a second representative nelson
uh represent likus your
maker of the motion
discussion
yes i don't know that i have to say a
whole lot more than the last one because
this does
a lot of the same things it just repeals
those two areas
[Music]
i will say
that i did write up for the history
teacher who came to see us
when we were talking about this build
history teacher that everybody liked and
wanted to have
his history teacher
i wrote up um
i just wrote down on here what the bill
says
but instead of listing all the things
each time i just picked one out and
listed it and he said this is a really
good bill i like this i said is it
unclear
he said well the fourth one
because of the way it's worded because
it has a double negative was a little
harder to understand but he really liked
it and i said this is the bill they're
trying to repeal
and he did not like that idea so i just
wanted to pass that on
but yeah same reasons reps and nelson do
you have anything at this state
thank you it's open for discussion
representative luno
thank you very much mr chair um so yeah
there may be some people that like the
current law i mean given the fact that
um
that when house bill what was it 544 um
last year
uh had substantial hearings in i think
it was in edna
i think it was i think it was an edna
and um and ended up
being retained
and
because it was so so um uh contentious
and there were a lot of people who
disagreed with with that bill but
clearly there were people that agreed
with it and uh and thought the best way
to get into law would be through the
budget process and jam it right into uh
to the budget
but um but this bill here house bill
yeah there's probably some people that
uh that disagree with it but at least
based on the uh the numbers there were
1149 uh in support 357 opposed and in
the prior bill there was 1201 in support
and 70 people opposed so i hope a lot of
these people are watching i hope they're
talking to their friends i hope they're
looking forward to the next election and
i hope they're willing to hold people
accountable
in this room and uh and and uh in the in
in the legislature to with the votes
they make and um and this is clearly a
law
that um
that is not um not supported by the vast
majority of granite staters and i think
we've got a great opportunity right here
and right now to repeal it thank you
further discussion
representatives
i did want to remind you that that
individual came in
uh in opposition in support of repealing
the law
he came in on one side based on what he
had heard and came out on the other side
having actually seen the law
thank you
is there any further discussion on this
representative woodcock
thank you chairman i would
ask all of you to go back to your notes
i'm sure you took in a wonderful manner
from this bill
and i always
ask you to remind yourself to
read through your notes from the
testimony we had by the rabbi from
nashua
and how clear he was how powerful he was
on the
necessity
for improving what we do
as required discrimination in a public
workplace in schools and support
this law uh repeal uh if you did take
the time to read his testimony or you
have a print out in your worksheets in
front of you i'd ask you to review it
again because it is powerful and it is
clearly the way that we should be going
this law needs to be repealed thank you
i'd like to just interject a little bit
of what i went through as a teacher in
the fourth grade and later as a school
principal and an administrator
when i was a teacher over in in maine
but
secondly when i went to alaska
we lived in a community
the only way to access that community
was by plane or by barge
and it was a native alaskan community
and my family and i my wife and kids
were distinctly a minority
and i watched my young girls which were
in first grade second grade as they were
taught in that classroom
there was no critical race theory
they went in there respecting everybody
else for what they were kids and kids
played together and learned together
and ate together
as kids
but when we inject
this theory that we've been talking
about if that were injected
into there we'd be definitely splitting
those kids up into various groups
and
we didn't do that
and of course i've mentioned before
the younger daughter came out able to
speak yupik
and that was her foreign language when
so i i feel that there's ways of of
doing what we are trying to achieve in
this country and we've gone a long way
over the last
years that this country has been in
existence
and we've had our downs and our ops
but we're moving forward
and we don't have to have a theory
telling us how to do that i think that
the kids
are we'll do it
i think we all will do it and we are
doing it so uh it the for the
institution to have to get in and
project
that we're going to have this
methodology and they're going to be
those instructors they're just like
there's people in any business
that
go a little bit further than they
probably should
instruction is something that i was
taught as a teacher there's a line
you've got to be able to identify where
that line is when you start injecting
and imparting your own personal opinion
they're going to ask you what party
you're part of
but if we use our higher order thinking
skills if we use use shared inquiry
there's a way of moving that around like
this
teacher did that's the history teacher
he didn't have to go into that he was
wise enough and had enough wisdom so he
could change that to a discussion where
they were getting at the facts and kids
were making up their own minds rather
than injecting
his perspective and that's what we have
to do as teachers we have to teach we
have to get into the facts we got to get
into the material but we don't want to
inject our own personal opinion
and i think we all must concur on that
now that's a basic truth i have as a
teacher
there are those folks which are not many
but there are some that come in are
young and inexperienced and they're
quick to push what they think they
should be pushing
and
they don't have that wisdom yet and
that's why we have folks that are you
know go through a couple years before
they become
a teacher that's you know uh the
experienced teacher i don't want to say
tenured and all that we don't like that
word do we represent woodcock but but
you know it there are you learn a lot as
you teach
so the inexperienced teacher needs that
help in identifying
the boundaries within instruction that's
a that's a given
so
i i'd like to think that we are moving
as a country i've i voted in support of
i don't want to see anybody seen as the
oppressor or the oppressed and all this
uh
i think we've just gone too far with
injecting this into our schools i think
that the kids can do this themselves and
they will if we don't if we as adults
don't get in the pathway and mess it up
so those my own two cents words of
pearls of wisdom i guess
mr chair yes uh inquiry of the chair
yeah yeah um on um just looking at 354 a
colon 31
and
would your read on that be that
this statute
would also apply to um
i think look at that where are you yeah
you're reading something that i don't
have yeah i'm looking at 831 so one of
one of the statutes that why don't you
read it
so so that that this law would would
begins with no public employer either
directly or through the use of an
outside contractor shall teach advocate
extract
instruct train and you know and it goes
on
but but would uh would this apply to
let's say a um
a non-public school that was contracted
by a school district to provide
educational services
it says public employer
it says no public employer so that's the
public school the school district either
directly meaning the school district
employs teachers
or through the use of an outside
contractor meaning the school district
contracts with a non-public school
and i forgot the statute on that 192 22
so so so the question is
does 354 a31
also apply to to a public employer like
such as a school district that contracts
its its educational services its
teaching
to an outside contractor either through
a non-public school or prendapod or um
or a um
no public employer in the state of new
hampshire contracts with a scholarship
organization
that then contracts with them
with with
trinity
school to teach
so so um
you know i think the reading on here is
very clear
that um that that a public employer is a
school district for sure a public
employer is the state of new hampshire
for sure
and that it's basically um
i i think it applies
certainly
much more broadly than um than than just
to teachers who are directly employed
with the school district
okay so that's the that's the intent of
the law
is that the yeah so where are you going
with all this so i mean i'm just trying
to understand that that um whether
that's the legislative intent of the
current law
um because this bill is trying to repeal
this law
and um and you know this would seem
to me
to to to put more than just uh teachers
who are directly employed by public
school districts in jeopardy of um of of
or the or the or the school district in
jeopardy of a violation of this statute
and and it would certainly apply to
everything that we're doing through 194
f
77g
and
and any any
contracted relationships that a school
district may have with a non-public
school
and that this bill here would would
actually repeal
those connections represent cordelia are
you anxious to respond to that yes thank
you excuse me yeah
um
a 30 uh is definitions and it uh does
define what a public public employee and
public employer are
um
you know i'm not sure where
you're going in terms of
um a school district contracting with a
non-public school
um but you mentioned also the
scholarship organization they don't
contract
with uh any school no no and and so i
was really clear on that thank you very
much representative cordelli so the
definition in a 30 354 a 30 for public
employer includes the state which i
talked about and any subdivision thereof
which i talked about a school did
a school district is a political
subdivision clearly both are
defined in this section as public
employers and then it goes on in eight
354 a 31 no public employer either
directly or through the use of an
outside contractor shall teach dot dot
dot
so the outside contractor
for the state
would be the scholarship organization
that further subcontracts
teaching so so that's one one
relationship a contracted relationship
the other relationship
would be a school district who contracts
with a non-public school for teaching
that's clearly covered in a 31 and then
the the one that presumably we all
you know believed was there is a school
district
who employs a teacher directly to teach
that's cool
it's pierce that you're driving down the
road of the efas here
et cetera and and uh
where you're going that's not that's not
the case
but it is it's part of the law it's part
of a 31. well we've had this discussion
with the efas many many many times
and well again tomorrow and we and
exactly if there's going to be a whole
host of bills coming up tomorrow which
i'm sure we will have this discussion
but we've had it during the hearing
process as well and i don't believe that
we need to get into the discussion on
efas when we're discussing this
particular bill well it's it's efas it's
non-public schools it's it's um
77g um
as well
and uh and obviously uh
public school districts that that
that um
that employ teachers directly
and uh and i think it's uh it's i i
don't think it's a question it's it's
it's here black and white
very very plainly stated i know we've
had a lot of discussions about efas but
uh but to be honest um mr chair i've
never heard
us talk about
this
statue
with respect to efas and but from the
conversation
here particularly on this side of the
room
i would have to conclude that you'd want
that to apply
to
every type of
education that is regulated by the by
the state
so
non-public school contracting with a
with a um with a public school uh uh uh
service provider contracting with an efa
i mean you wouldn't want them teaching
any of these things either right
cordelli thank you
um you mentioned 77g which is the tax
credit scholarship program
um similar to
efas the education freedom accounts
funds
from either go to
the family
the family then
makes an agreement with a service
provider
the children's scholarship fund does not
contract with anyone
in terms of providing educational
services
if you're
thinking of
religious schools along the way
you should take a look at 354 a 18 which
is
an exemption that has a
supreme court and all sorts of court
basis for exemptions for religious
organizations
so
you know i don't see that
the point is applicable to 354 for the
scholarship organization when it comes
to tax credit scholarships or to
the education freedom accounts so so um
thank you very much representative
cordelli so so the the earlier reference
that you said it's clearly not part of
this this block of of uh freedom from
discrimination um um
and um uh and i think and thank you very
much for the clarification with regards
to 77g
scholarship accounts i guess i was not
aware that that money went from the
scholarship organization directly to the
parent as opposed to through the
scholarship organization to the the
contracted
education service provider that sort of
brings up
additional questions about the
scholarship program that would not be
relevant to 1576 but i think the um i
think the connection that um that that
that um that 354 a 31 has
um to um to to
as a requirement on public employers
which include the state or any
subdivision thereof
and the fact that the scholarship
organization is the subcontractor of the
state
and service providers are subcontractors
of the scholarship organization because
we've heard testimony here that that's
in fact how how this is being done
um
and and that
there are certainly instances where
non-public schools are contracted by uh
school districts
which are clear enough um public
employers um as as a political
subdivision as defined in in a 30 that
um that that that this this is pretty
clear
and uh we we haven't heard from i mean
we've we've we've heard from a lot of
organizations on um uh on the substance
of 1576 and the substance of the current
law you know including teachers we've
heard from aclu we've heard from new
futures we've heard from school board
members
um
uh
and many others and um
but
but i i think it's it's it's very clear
here that um that the current law
also applies to uh non-public schools
and um and uh organ service providers
that are contracted through scholarship
organizations i don't see how you read
it any other way
well just for a point of clarification
the education tax credit those monies
are not state monies to begin with
and when we're talking about the efas i
i think we need to sit down and
have an education lesson here on on on
how the money uh is transferred down
um that's worthy of another discussion i
i would like to try to
uh correct some of your insights or your
perspectives and how they're not
insights there were the words
well
words matter right
well we've heard that statement before
are you done here with uh we're on uh
1576 here so if we repeal if we repeal
this by passing this then then all of
that connection goes away
thank you
not seeing any thank you
madam clerk would you please call the
roll
yes thank you
this is house bill 1576 repealing the
law relative to certain discrimination
in public workplaces and education
the motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is a yes
representative simon yes representative
lacus yes representative moffett yes
representative hobson
yes
representative ford yes representative
soti
representative nelson
representative
no
representative waltz no
president cornell no
representative tiana no
representative
no
and chairman ladd yes
so the itl passes 10 to 9.
okay um
we're going to take a short break here
for about five minutes i see some people
getting up and walking around i think we
some of us have to take a little walk
here me mr chair would there be a
minority report yeah there there will be
a minority report for sure that's i
assume that right there representative
mullen okay thank you
okay yeah thank you
thank you so we're going to take a
five minute break here
so people can get up and stretch a
yeah it's time to kick it into turbo
of course it feels better
even though i kind of feel like in a fog
lately but today it feels a little bit
my jinx myself i'm not gonna say well
they might have competed in division two
right
ugh
um
representatives can you see if there's
represent like us
could you see if anybody's in the
hallway please
okay
which way is this
did you get a copy of this
is that
yeah
okay we're going to go ahead with 1607
prohibiting unlawful discrimination in
representative cordell you recognized
for a motion uh thank you mr chairman i
would like to move uh itl on uh hb 1607.
perhaps
i would like to second that motion
please thank you very much so the motion
on the table is itl represent cordell
you made the motion do you care to
discuss your motion
uh briefly thank you
um
series of comments at the hearing were
made
[Music]
by the
chair of the human
i think that this
legislation
confusion
and
would undermine the human rights
commission
by transferring some
duties that now belong with the human
rights commission to this uh state board
of education
um i i don't know how they would
deal with what is proposed
in this legislation
and for those reasons i
representative litchfield
i'm all set thank you
it's open to discussion yes
representative thank you very much mr
chair and um um i would i would ask the
chair if um
if um and i know i know there's a the
the pending motion is itl and so
so we're not in a in a place where we
can introduce uh make a motion but you
may discuss but we may discuss so if if
if it's okay i'd like to
just pass it over to linda to do that
thank you mr chair
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
doing this
um
this bill uh
has i have an amendment for it it was a
little confusing
in the beginning but the the amendment
that i passed around i hope makes it
clear that my
intention on this is to
extend
the
protections for discrimination
not only to our public schools but to
any entity receiving public funding in
uh public school private school
approved schools for tuition programs or
educational vendors
and that
the reason that this bill
was originally
set forth
is that
it actually
takes what the public schools have to
abide by and what our state has to abide
by in employment and housing and extends
it uh to
wherever we're extending uh public
education
and
um i'm sorry that uh the person from the
human rights commission
and i didn't get a chance to actually
discuss this bill beforehand we we
played phone tag for about a month i
think
and um essentially
the commission
is based on housing
and employment practices whereas the
department of education's job and the
school board's job
role is to protect students
and to oversee the public school system
uh and the public and the education of
our children
and so therefore i think that
um even though uh she went into quite an
uh explanation on things that certainly
this law does not interfere with her
work at all
in fact it complements it and extends it
and on the
reverse side of it
it gives the role of the state school
board and the department of education
the the role to oversee
uh that discrimination is not happening
within their purview so and um
i hope that this uh amendment clears
at least a little bit up on the
intention
uh for the bill thank you
thank you very much uh is there
discussion on the bill we've we've had
discussion on the
you know on a amendment that's not been
introduced but it is available for you
to look at
um
allow in the discussion
discussion going either way either on
that you know amendment or or on
primarily we have to address the bill
itself
representative mullen
thank you mr chair uh we have spent a
considerable amount of time this morning
talking about
how to make sure that people are not
discriminated against i think this bill
actually complements that discussion
by extending the
rights of non-discrimination to
places other than just the public
schools
and again i'm going to ask the same
question today that i asked during the
hearing last week and that is
why would we not expect the state board
of education
to follow the same anti-discrimination
language that we have placed into law in
a multitude of other places when i read
representative tanner's uh
amendment and the language in it
um the protected classes are the same
that
appear in any of the updated laws that
we have
so it looks to me like this is a
housekeeping thing in terms of the state
board of ed
thank you
um
the
lady that we heard from
yeah was saying that it was that would
complicated or confusing because
education was added
purview
and
we're talking about oh we need to extend
this to all these places it exists
everywhere you need to go back to 354 a1
which says this chapter shall be known
as the law against discrimination it
will be deemed an exercise of the police
power of the state for the protection of
the public welfare health and peace of
the people of the state
and in fulfillment of the provisions of
the constitution of this state
concerning civil rights it then goes on
and and lists all of the
you know the things that shall be
discriminated used to discriminate and
to say that they're therefore setting up
a state agency
created with the power to eliminate and
prevent discrimination
and
and it does say places of public
accommodation housing accommodations etc
but
education was added to that and that's
what she said she's now in charge and
does deal with the education as well so
taking that away from the organization
that's set up to deal with this and
putting it back on the state board of
education obviously the state board of
education has some responsibility
anyways because we all do
based on this but
it should be in the purview of the
organization that was set up to deal
with it they have the lawyers they have
the expertise
they have the people that investigate
they have all that stuff yes she sat
here and gave us all of those things and
she said she was not in support of this
because she already does this and and um
we'd just be
messing it up
representing luna
thank you very much mr chair uh first of
all director malika did not say that she
was not uh in support of it she she
certainly brought up the fact that um
that 354
a has uh has a number of sections that
could potentially um
overlap with uh with with even the
existing
law that uh that that that this bill
isn't
intended to amend
but but when you take a look
specifically and director mallika did
did testify to this
that 354 a colon 27 the opportunity for
public education without discrimination
a civil right
only applies to public schools it does
not apply
uh the same way we were talking about
the last the last bill to public
employers
and subdivisions and content
and organizations that contract to to uh
to the state and subdivisions this
the section that that the director uh
specified a colon 27
only applies to public schools the
current statute
in the the current statute that that
this bill is amending 86 colon 11
also currently applies to public schools
ensure that there shall be no unlawful
discrimination in any public school and
what the bill goes on to do is to amend
that so that it's not just in any public
school but any
private any entity that's receiving
public funding
public funding a public school private
school approved school for tuition
programs or an educational vendor
um so so in fact the the
the language in this bill
does not overlap with the uh with the
human rights commission's um charge
and statutory um uh requirements in a27
it um specifically extends the existing
requirements that the state board has to
make sure that it's guaranteeing
uh no unlawful discrimination not just
in our public schools but in any of the
the educational environments that are
that are uh being paid for by public tax
dollars so so
it's
it's not inconsistent with um with the
human rights commission's work it's not
in contradiction or in
or
or overlaps with it and it certainly is
something that uh is clearly an
oversight in the um in the existing
law uh for the state board so i i think
we should all i hope we can all support
this thank you
further discussion
yes represent cordelia
thank you
um
by
putting this language into statute
and applying it to private schools and
so
yeah
it's fuzzy the way it's written the
amendment makes sense
yeah i'm looking at it right i
understand yes right um it would it
would
in uh in effect
um
do away with the
exemption for religious organization
that's in the human rights
statutes 354 a18
that is well founded in court decisions
and basically
i can read it to you if that's all right
mr chairman it's not too long
354 a18 exemption for religious
organizations nothing contained in this
chapter shall be construed to bar any
religious or denominational institution
or organization or organization operated
for charitable or educational purposes
which is operated supervised or
controlled by or in connection with a
religious organization from limited
to or giving preference to persons of
the same religion or denomination or
from making such selection as is
calculated by such organization to
promote the original religious
principles for which it is established
or maintained
by implementing
or moving forward with 1607
when it comes to education um this
exemption for uh religious organization
would uh basically be bypassed and um
so i i think that based on
on on that um based on the fact that um
uh i i don't know i i don't know if
anyone else has heard any problems um
anyone has uh complained about with the
operation of the human rights commission
um but i
i see no reason for um 1607.
further discussion representative tanner
and then representative waltz
thank you uh mr chair and under 186
colon 11 the duties of the state school
board of education
under sections 33
it clearly states discrimination the
school board and i'll just it it says
the state board of education shall at
the beginning of the chapter ensure that
there shall be no
unlawful discrimination in any public
school against and it goes into all the
different areas that i've gone in so
obviously between that and title ix
discrimination
statutes the school district and the
department of education has dealt with
this issue
and deals with this issue and refers
these issues to
the human rights commission if they feel
it's necessary but it should not be
passed the the ideal on this should not
be based on the fact that the department
of education cannot handle this or the
state school board cannot handle it i
would also remind us that
in our constitution uh in part one
there's um
there's
a section that says that no person shall
be
no citizen shall pay for religious
education
and so there's some question that there
are some hazy areas
about the
representative cordelli is talking about
when it comes to
public education paid for through the
state so thank you
representative waltz thank you um i'd
just like to address what representative
cordelli said and that is
the amendment here that's before me in
no way abrogates section 18 that
representative cordelli read to us it's
still fully in effect however
if an institution chooses to cha take
public monies then there are limitations
on discrimination but if they don't take
the public monies section 18 is fully in
effect this does not make section 18 go
away in any way
so i think that was misleading and i'd
just like to make clear that we're only
talking here institutions that take
public monies and we as a governmental
body have an institut have an interest
in regulating people who take public
monies in the kind of discrimination
does public money include public
services in a private school i'll give
you an example the fire department comes
to a private school
the fire department is paid by
taxpayers
issue i don't believe so i think money
means money well they have
so that would you wouldn't have a
problem with that happening with the
fire department going to a school
correct
okay now one other example if you don't
mind uh for our full declaration my
son's a catholic priest
and his church put on
a shelter in the church for the homeless
okay i know it's a little different from
schools but if a school also goes on and
collects money to give
to
a
black orphanage or some particular group
is that a problem too if they take some
money from something crazy i don't know
buying a new projector or new safety
defibrillator or something
so i you lost me a little bit in this
between collecting money and and taking
money i mean so for example
if a school accepts money for example to
pay say a physical therapist that's
clearly taking money okay if you've got
a local volunteer fire department coming
in and doing an anti
you know a stop drop enroll program for
first graders
i don't think that is accepting public
money but i do think that if we've got
public money paying say for a physical
therapist at a school that is accepting
public money and and i'm not quite sure
where you're i couldn't understand your
question to see where you were trying to
draw the line but i hope that clarifies
it
thank you i i can understand where i'm
very confusing i apologize for that to
everybody
but just concerned where this would lead
where you draw the line from public
money
and money that is used by a private
school you're encouraging somebody if
they accept the money don't or don't
don't take any uh student who could have
a problem
reading this uh you know you don't want
anybody who has a mentally disability
because uh you take public funding if
you got some on a private school they
gave you some money or a teacher goes in
and if if you had somebody severely
emotionally ill severely do they have to
take a student in if they take money at
private school
and you're somebody with severe psych
i've seen this
on a special ed teacher most of my
career some severe psychological issues
because it'll be money indirectly you
know what i'm not over my skis and i'm
not going to answer that because i don't
know the the short answer to that and
and you know i i i don't know
to answer that special one has special
rules and i i don't know how they apply
and if if i understood that you know i'd
answer it but i just don't know that's
fine i accept that
go ahead yeah just uh clarification on
on that and i'm not an expert on in this
area and um and i think this
conversation could probably benefit from
having somebody like attorneys ellen
weigh in on that but specifically to
represent nelson's question about
student with special with an iep
that
that the
the district of residence is responsible
for those iep classes i wouldn't
consider that to be funding
a private school if if the student was
was was placed there
through something other than a parental
you know i think a parental placement
negates that but then that's not public
funded
in that case but um
but but i think the i think the the
the legislative intent
here and representative tanner correct
me if i'm if i'm
mis
if i misstate this but any entity
receiving public funding
so so um and that's that's not through
you know candy sales or or something
like that but um but you know with a a
contract with a um with a
let's say a school district to provide
services for those um uh for those
students and being being funded to
provide those services as opposed to um
you know paying to have those those
services provided by the resident
district
i'd need a little clarification i can
remember as a
school principal i received title 1
monies which are federal dollars
and within the requirements or the
regulations
i was required to provide service to the
private school up the road with some of
those dollars some service
now
the dollar stopped at my door
and i employed
a remedial reading teacher
with title one
some of those dollars i believe at that
time required may not be now but
in years ago i then had to provide some
support to the private school which was
just up the road
is that is that that's a service though
but that's not
money flowing
so that's that would not come underneath
this
as you're you're you're okay
okay represent like us
my concern
is an unintended consequence of this
let's say a private school
is
has taken in placement students
who have
certain disabilities and they're fine
with that
and then but now they're taking public
money
because they have students who are going
there that are be paid for publicly that
they have taken in
i hope
if i'm incorrect let me know but if
you're taking students that are paid for
by the district
is that not public money
and then if you you then cannot turn
down a student that you don't feel you
have the you that you could
address properly right and so
when we put this law in the unintended
consequences if you say no you have to
take this student because you take
public money that those private schools
are going to say fine we won't take any
students so that then we won't be taking
public money and that's going to hurt
all the students that they turn away
because they don't want to have to take
every student regardless representative
woodcock
thank you i would disagree with the
thinking of representatives because
it can't turn away that's not what
they're talking about they're talking
about they can't discriminate
and i find this this i'm looking at the
amendment which clarified the original
bill
that makes it a little clearer i i just
have a really hard time to understand
why would we want to not pass this when
all it says is as a group we don't want
discrimination for any reason in schools
public or private that's what this says
so if you don't agree with that then say
okay let's discriminate
that's the part that really concerns me
this is really a simple piece that's
just expanding that everyone's covered
and i was so it's just that's i find it
hard to understand why would we why we
would not want to embrace this uh
representation's original bill and
particularly her amendment
thank you
representative uh cordelli
thank you mr chairman
in terms of public monies and
going to
religious
educational organizations and the
exemption
section 189 colon 49
of the statutes is
child benefit services and enables a
school board of any school district to
provide
funds to
any non-public school in in the area for
nurse services etc
and that does happen
in hampton
sacred heart school has
been
awarded in the 40 45 000 range
annually based on a school warrant
uh article
money um
from this description of one of the
articles
it specifies funds to help cover a nurse
education technology supplies and
textbooks
so they received
uh
clearly public funds
um and they are a religious institution
um
so
again i i think that
um
the exemption in 354 18
would certainly be in question whether
that would apply in this case if this
legislation is passed
and i think
we would have a lot of
legal difficulties
if
represent tanner
thank you so does this does that mean
that that those institutions
are
are discriminating or against uh the
protected classes under new hampshire's
no but
in hiring for instance
they don't want to hire
someone with um
a belief system contrary to their
religious beliefs
um
issues like like that there there is in
all sorts of legal precedent um
this exemption for religious
organization
uh represent tanner can you please
explain to me
what what do you mean by educational
vendor
is there a definition for that term
um i haven't
researched back through
ols did not research back through but
typically vendors are people that
are organizations that are contracted
services
by a school district and
we know that now school districts can
contract out and and
uh do provide educational services
through
um
non-profit and for-profit vendors vendor
is a commercial entity i would say that
offers services
okay
representative mullen then would i can
answer that question uh
with regards to what an educational
vendor is yeah we
have tutoring agencies in town
that offer after-school tutoring
services to parents but they also
sometimes offer programmatic things
during the day
so that a school district could actually
hire somebody to work
with a student if they were
so inclined to need a math tutor or a
science tutor or whatever
that would be considered to be an
educational vendor because they wouldn't
be
an employee of the public school system
but they would be hired by the public
school system to perform some sort of
task or skill with a student
thank you see represent woodcock then
represent moffitt i want to thank
representative mullen for taking my
answer
but beyond that but beyond that we won't
hold any grudges later
but be honest the other part is as
representative and we all are well aware
many school districts
uh contract with private particularly in
the smaller towns private schools and
they are allowed to send a youngster
from a public school to a private school
under the school board authority we know
that but once again i want to go back to
this this is talking about why would we
want to
send a student to a school a school
public or private with our funding
knowing they discriminate that's the
whole point this just says you can't
discriminate this is really simple this
just says you can't discriminate
you're either for discrimination or
you're against it it's simple this is
simple
representative
um it's a type of bill or legislation
that weaponizes uh attorneys to uh you
know target certain schools or programs
uh
at the hearing it came up i brought it
up there were a couple of uh small
public charter schools that only cater
or allow girls
so if this were to pass speaking of
representative lekkis's point about
unintended consequences
uh it's i don't know that would happen
hope it would not but i could easily see
somebody who identified this admits his
gender identity so someone who
identifies as a female wanting to go to
that school but forget that
if this school is exclusive to males
a flat out male could cite the statute
and say i need to be in this school i
want to be in this school it's in my
neighborhood that's where i want to be
and this law says i need to be at this
girl school that's
represent like us
thank you yeah that that was my point is
that it's not just discriminate or not
discriminate because it has that phrase
shall be no denial
which
um
to the benefits of their programs or
activities and that's the sticking point
and for me it's it's and i know there
are
still girls schools i believe
i was told there are still some girl
schools in the state
[Music]
but for me it's more the
i'm concerned about the mental or
physical disability because some schools
are not prepared
to deal with certain
disabilities
and
we've seen we've heard from parents
who've said that their child was turned
down from this public school and that
public school and then that private
school it happens there are school
schools just say i can't we don't have
the facilities we don't have the setup
we can't do a good job educating that
child based on that child's particular
disabilities
and so the concern is
if this passes because they then can't
deny based on that
that they will just say all right i'm
taking no public money which means i'm
not taking those kids that i can service
and that's
that's the point that's the critical
piece that's in here that makes it
untenable
is the no denial to any person
of the benefits of the program
and so it says either you have to take
everybody whether you can handle them or
not
or
schools are likely to say then i'll take
nobody and that's the limiting that's
the unintended consequence and that's
the language in this that isn't just
discriminate or not discriminate
it's sometimes we just can't handle
certain
you know
certain disabilities we've seen it we
know we've heard one mom multiple times
thank you
representative tanner
part of that
uh opposition is to words that are
already in statute
but
uh director malachi clearly stated that
there are exemptions for same-sex
schools
uh that there are exemptions under the
law
and and exemptions that people can apply
for to run an all-girls school or an
all-boys school so i think that that
kind of covers that little area of it
and as far as disabilities are concerned
we have the americans for disability act
and we have special education
legislation and i think what you just
described would be illegal
if a public school denied
the
person to come in because they had a
special need they have to find
accommodations for that that is that is
under the law the the sending
organization sending district and
correct me if i'm wrong but i believe
this sending district has to provide
accommodations in some respect maybe not
at that public school maybe they send
them they have out of
out of uh school tuition programs for
them but they they have to take care of
that child they can't just throw them
out on the street because they aren't a
further discussion represent likus
that's not what we've heard and that's
not i mean one mom who came and
testified multiple times but i've heard
it from other parents and read it from
other parents as well that their kids
are denied
from public schools
and then from private schools that mom
said her school
wouldn't take her son
the neighboring public schools wouldn't
take her son
and the private school wouldn't take her
son because none of them could
accommodate him
and she's now homeschooling so
if it's the law it sure isn't being
enforced
further discussion representative
cordelli thank you
our open enrollment
states
open enrollment schools may select
pupils on the basis of aptitude academic
achievement or need
provided that this is selection is
directly related to the academic goals
of the school
so
that's
currently in statute
not seeing madam clerk would you please
call the roll
yes thank you this is house bill 1607
prohibiting unlawful discrimination in
public and non-public schools the motion
representative cordelli
yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative simon yes
representative lacas yes representative
moffat yes
representative hobson yes representative
oliv ford
yes representative soti yes i'm sam
nelson
representative luno no representative
waltz no
no
is that representative cornell no okay
representative tanner absolutely not no
representative allison
no
and chairman ladd yes
so the itl passes 10 to 9.
okay there will be i'm sure a minority
report from whom
okay representative tanner
yeah that's the amendment that's sitting
right there and would i attach it to
this or no because we didn't put it in
the folder put it in folder as a
yeah yeah he will yeah
okay we have i'm going to have one more
bill here before we take a break for
lunch and that's 1638
relative to grievances under the right
to freedom from discrimination and
so it's hb 16 38 represent like us for a
motion
move we itl
and reps and hobson
we have a motion made by represent lake
is second by represent hobson itl is the
motion representative like us are you uh
do you have any discussion
yes i do
first off i don't see an amendment and
one of the issues was within three days
of receipt is that school days or not
but the other part in the part that for
me is the most compelling
[Music]
the parent is supposed to go first by
law now to the superintendent
and if the superintendent is the one
initiating the discrimination
as we have seen happening
in a number of school districts and we
did have that one speaker come in with
scads of of um documentation and she
sent us a whole bunch of stuff if we
the parent will not want to go to the
superintendent for fear of retribution
against their child
and the other thing we keep talking
about oh well these civil suits and
whatever let me tell you a parent is
going to do everything they can first
because civil suits cost money you have
to hire a lawyer etc they're not just
going to indiscriminately say oh i'm
just going to go do a civil suit no
there have been plenty of people already
upset at
school districts etc who have not
a filed suit because it costs money that
they don't have
so they are going to go through all the
appropriate
and if it's not the local superintendent
they will go there first because they
don't want to spend that money unless
they're not getting satisfied any other
way
but
this would make into law that they need
to go first
to the superintendent
and if the superintendent
as i said is the one
pushing
then
and there have been parents who have
spoken and said that then their child
was
given a hard time discriminated against
bullied whatever because the parent came
and complained
so
i don't want to make it law that they
have to go to the superintendent that's
representative hobson do you have any
further discussion no i have nothing to
add
discussion from the committee
representative uh luna thank you very
much mr chair so you know this this
certainly built um
1638 builds on a lot of our discussions
that we've had throughout the morning
and um and
the um
and i think it does so in a very
practical and pragmatic way
it provides a um
a process
for
somebody who feels aggrieved in terms of
their their um
in term
somebody that feels aggrieved
to be able to um
to go through
their local school board to the
superintendent to the state board of
education and then to the civil rights
uh commission
should um should any of the um the the
the um you know banned um
content
uh you know
have been taught or they feel they feel
like they've been aggrieved in those
those those earlier sections
and um
and it really and it replaces the uh
really the the part that i think puts
the greatest chill
in um in the band in the band content
um in the censorship is the onerous
remedy that's currently in statute in
354 834
which um now you've got you've got free
reign on a write a private action and
i'm sure you'll find you can find
attorneys who will take uh these matters
under under consideration and and i mean
under
under um what's the word i'm using um um
yeah on contingency on contingency
and uh and go after trouble damages and
and all that type of stuff so so that
parts gets repealed and um and and what
gets put in place i think is a very well
thought out um
um
escalation through your local school
board the superintendent state board of
education and the civil rights
commission to um uh to have your um your
your your your case adjudicated and um
and i think that will help take the
chill
out of um out of these the banned cons
concepts act thank you thank you
representative mullin
thank you mr chair
um
sitting here listening to the argument
i'm struck by the idea that certainly
there have to be cases where
superintendents parents find fault with
the superintendent and there has to be
some sort of
mitigation plan at the local level in
place for situations like that i would
ask representative litchfield if she
would mind
putting on her school current school
board hat
and
educating us about what happens in your
school district
if a parent has a gripe against the
superintendent does it go to the school
board is there a mechanism for that
you don't have to answer that but you're
can i restate it has has anything ever
come
to the school board where you are and
i'm not sure which town that is but i
know that it's somewhere here
um
it's i i know it's somewhere under new
hampshire law right thank you
representative hobson has anything has
there ever been a situation or if
anybody else is on a school board that's
in the room
um
has there been a situation in which
the
offending party was the superintendent
because i can speak a little bit to what
has happened
in the past in bedford but i'm not a
perhaps uh uh we have the department
here
do you have you ever had a parent
come and say i'm i'm just having a tough
a tough time you know or there's an
issue that's come up and i don't agree
with what the superintendent is doing do
you advise them to go see their school
board or is there any assistance that's
given from the department as far as
representative luna with that
contingency thing
for a lawyer who's never had a client i
was pretty good um
so
frank doesn't know that i'm billing him
but i am
i see you frank um so yes the the
department gets a lot of complaints your
question's very uh
broad in general um
but yes we get complaints about uh
superintendents and complaints about
individual educators
so we would have to narrow down what the
exact complaint is but yes we have
received complaints over the years
about individual superintendents and
generally speaking depending on what the
issue is
we can either assist in that sometimes
we assist in having that conversation
um
kind of facilitating that informally
or we will refer them to their school
board
so if i have agreements
and it's dealing with discrimination of
some kind and i'm not getting resolved
through the superintendent
if i contact your office or somebody at
doe
you may want to set up a meeting would
facilitate a meeting with a
superintendent or would you act as sort
of like a mediator in that or so
under the current law if it deals with
discrimination we would refer them to
the human rights commission okay
and that is the that is
how the law is currently written and
interpreted and the attorney general's
office put out an opinion on that in
july
and so that is where all those
grievances uh whether they involve the
superintendent or not would be directed
i see and so i don't even know if we
would um
drill down to the level of who this
grievance is actually about
those matters
under the law is currently written are
handled exclusively by the human rights
commission thank you does anybody else
have a question representative of the
doe yes representative tanner uh thank
you for taking my question
how many
superintendents are there currently in
the state of new hampshire just
approximate oh my gosh i'm going how
many sausages i'm going to phone a
friend and reach out to the nea
how many superintendents are there
there's got to be over 100 i would say
i i honestly i don't know the number off
the top of my head i'm i'm happy to get
back to you but but let's say let's say
it's over i think it's over 100 because
i think you know the sau numbers at
least go up to 90s
it goes up to about 120 but some of
these are not all of them
some of them have superintendent
services having presented to all of the
superintendents i can tell you it's at
least a hundred if not more okay so um
could you give me you say that you do
get uh complaints could you kind of
quantify that a little bit better uh
like on a yearly average would you say
one to five five to ten
fifty
a 100 how many do you think you get
uh if we were to go broadly outside of
the claim of discrimination no just
discrimination just discrimination which
i it's hard to give a number because
those complaints are given to another
agency
we just don't have that
that number but if i were to
based on the very limited interaction
we've had
and this is an estimate
i'm asking for a ballpark figure one to
five five to ten i'd say ten to ten to
twenty okay
but again i want to be clear on
discrimination
on discrimination i feel i feel that's
maybe
10 to 15 okay um but again
those complaints are sent to another
agency they do not fall within the
jurisdiction of the department of
education to adjudicate the department
of education will impose discipline on a
credential if there is a finding by the
human rights commission so and when you
just follow
so when you talk about that
um are
are those complaints like
uh
that discrimination happened within the
school
came to the superintendent's office
and the superintendent
didn't um
adjudicate that the way
the per person that was discriminated
against
because uh
so therefore the complaint is against
the superintendent rather than where the
based on that particular fact pattern i
think there are far less
okay complaints thank you
are there any other uh
questions yes represent hobson
thank you mr chair and thank you miss
fenton for taking my question
so currently if discrimination is
believed to be going on
a person can go right to the human
rights commission and fill out a
complaint i think we heard miss malachi
testify that it was immediately taken up
correct
i i don't know if you i can't speak okay
or her testimony okay
this process would add a significant
amount of time to that discrimination
accusation for lack of a better word do
you have any idea how long this process
might take compared to
going through the civil rights
commission
my understanding i i don't have a set
i think you alluded to the answer in
your question it
as written that law would add an
additional step but in terms of
comparing the time uh that exists
currently to what is proposed i i'm not
any other yes represent tanner
so
thank you for taking my question so as
this bill is written
what happens to charter schools
because there isn't a superintendent in
a charter school is there
uh so charter schools as you know have a
uh i think it's a
coo or ceo i forget to have a laws
written without my book i'm useless uh
apparently but um no they do not have a
superintendent but they have the
functional equivalent of one
so
so would they in in order to be
uh covered by this law since they are a
public school as well would the would
the would this bill have to be
uh amended to include a procedure for
specifically for charter schools that go
through whatever um and i'm not sure
that
that there are schools perhaps that that
don't have the
same that we contract with maybe that
don't have this have the same structure
as a
as the public schools with
superintendents in other words this this
has a you know a series going through
they don't have a school board for
example
if you were to apply it to charter
schools and i i do not have the language
of the bill in front of me and i
apologize for that but if you were to
apply it to charter schools 194b is very
clear that unless explicitly stated in
other areas of the law
those laws are not
equally applicable to charter schools
charter schools have their own carve out
and
this legislative body has dealt with
that in a variety of areas
making those laws applicable to charter
schools
in terms of your other question as to
other entities in which that can be
applicable to i'm not in a position to
say
we would have to take them
on each individual situation
but
certainly
the language as written sounds narrowly
tailored to involve superintendents in
your right to identify that there are
other entities that have different
terminology thank you so uh in your
legal opinion
uh you wouldn't think that this applied
it's not really my legal opinion 194b
says very clearly
that if a lot were to apply it it i
don't have the exact language with me
but i i can point you to that language
um and it's something this legislative
body has dealt with anytime charter
schools are brought up
that's the way 194b was was written it
has to be clearly uh stated that it is
applicable to charter schools okay thank
you
further questions
thank you very much diana thank you
you're a general with three stars today
that's fantastic
okay
uh further discussion on this bill
not seeing any
madam clerk would you please call the
roll
yes this is house bill 1638
relative to grievances under the right
to freedom from discrimination in public
workplaces in education the motion on
the table is itl representative cordelli
yes
representative glitchfield is yes
representative simon yes representative
blakis yes represent moffitt
yes
represent hobson
yes represent ford
yes
representative nelson yes
representative luna no representative
no
representative cornell no representative
tanner no representative allison
no representation woodcock
representative muse
no
hall
okay who's going to write the uh
and
otp
okay got that
okay we're gonna take a break now uh
we're gonna break until one o'clock
uh we will have a caucus in this room
and so um yes you want to come you're
but you've got to bring the pizza
yeah
is
testing
okay we're going to commence with the
executive sessions this afternoon we're
on hb 1313
relative to the rights to rights to
freedom from discrimination and higher
education
i'm going to hand the gavel over to
thank you mr chairman
this is house bill 1313 relative to the
rights
to freedom from discrimination in higher
education and i'll call on the chairman
for a motion
thank you very much mr chair i'd like to
uh make the motion of interim study on
1313.
representative hopson thank you
uh mr chairman would you like to uh
offer some comments yeah we've had a lot
of discussion on um discrimination in
education today
and this uh bill is uh relevant to
higher education
and at this point in time i i think it's
it's it's not timely it's uh
inappropriate to move forward it with it
for several reasons we're going through
a lot of organization restructuring
we have a lot of movement in terms of
administration
we have the president of
of unh now becoming the chancellor of
the school system as well as being
president
uh with that there's also a lot of need
for further understanding of the
academic freedom that exists at the
university level and uh instruction that
results from it and i i think would be
premature in our acting on this bill at
this time
uh representative
hopson any comments no i i would agree
with everything the chair said thank you
thank you any other
comments from the committee
uh sure thank you very much mr chair um
uh
i uh i very much appreciate the
representative lad's motion for interim
study i certainly do not believe this
bill is ready for for prime time
i am most likely going to support the
interim study
but i could certainly also support an
itl on uh on 1313 as well knowing that
um that
if uh if in fact there are problems and
that are that are a situation that needs
to be addressed that uh that this bill
would require substantial amount of work
uh in in um uh in cooperation with um
and collaboration i should say with the
um leadership both at the community
colleges and university system so thanks
very much
scene none
this is house bill 1313 relative to
rights to freedom from discrimination in
higher education the motion on the table
is interim study
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is a yes
representative simon yes representative
blakis yes represent moffett yes
represent hobson yes represent ford
yes
yes from sam nelson yes representative
luno
yes
no i would rather see itl so i'm going
to vote no
okay representative cornell yes
president tanner yes
representative ellison yes
representative mullin
yes
from sam woodcock yeah
represent muse yes
yes
and chairman ladd yes
okay so interim study 18 18-1
is consent okay with that
great thank you
okay
thank you very much to all
um
hb
1366 relative to cooperative school
board reapportionment
i look to representative moffat for a
motion
thank you mr i would like to mo
make a motion for interim study i s on
this
hey second thank you very much uh
representative
uh briefly mr chair i actually was
initially going to make an otp
recommendation on this this bill if you
remember if you look at it
uh would have made it or would make it
easier to submit petition articles
locally
right now
irsa 195 colon 22 requires a proposal to
show signatures of 10
of a cooperative district's qualified
voters which i i some of us thought was
daunting especially some
districts would have hunt you'd need
hundreds of signatures
but i'm not gonna motion otp there are
some like uh
eight
sb2 towns
that may have some different dynamics so
anyway uh for that reason i think we
need to look at some pieces of this a
little bit more
representative ditto ditto
further discussion from the committee
not seeing any madam clerk would you
please call the roll
yes this is house bill 1366 relative to
cooperative school board reapportionment
uh the motion on the table is interim
study
glenn cordelli
yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative simon yes
representative lakis yes represent
moffitt
yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford yes representative soti yes
representative nelson
represent luna yes
represent waltz yes from sam cornell yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison
representative muse yes
represent hall yes and chairman ladd yes
okay
okay the next bill which we have on the
docket is
hb 1399
relative to school district withdrawal
um
hb 1399 i call on chairman ladd for a
motion thank you very much i make a
a second high second
thank you
comments mr chairman thank you very much
withdrawal from a cooperative school
districts as we all know is a very very
complex issue
disillusionment properties
where kids go to school et cetera et
cetera et cetera we've all discussed it
and um all these bills uh
to act on them singularly is going to be
a problem
to
uh
we need to look at them all and and do a
thorough interim study i believe interim
study right now would even be better
than a so-called commission scene that
we could start this right off in the
spring
comp forward and have people participate
that are not necessarily on that
particular committee as we usually do
and get that input from
those people have ownership in the
cooperative school districts be
administration be it school board
members be it public parents cetera
and hopefully we can get some resolution
on this we've been hacking away at this
for years the last time we did it was in
and even at the if you look at that
commission report
there are still several recommendations
dealing with disillusionment depending
upon the size of your district the
number of districts within that
cooperative this needs further work so i
that's why i've recommended interim
study
uh representative lake has any comment
any further comments from anyone on the
committee
scene none
madam clerk
house bill 1399 relative to school
district withdrawal from a cooperative
school district the motion on the tables
in terms of study
representative
cordelli yes representative litchfield
is yes representative simon yes
representative
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
representative cornell yes i'm sam
tanner yes
representative ellison
represent mullin yes what is that
woodcock yeah representative muse yes
where sam hall yes and chairman ladd yes
consent
in the objections thank you
uh the next bill 1646
we have amendment coming here we have
not received this amendment this is a
bill that deals with cooperative school
districts
and let's say we have three districts
within the cooperative one district may
have
two representatives
the other two districts may have won
each the issue was should those people
be elected by the people within the
district
rather than at large
and that's an issue that we had some
discussion on
and and uh
i would like us to have the opportunity
to look at that amendment and make the
decision on that when we get ahold of
that at a later date so my
recommendation to the group right here
is that we not take it up today
yes represent woodcock thank you
chairman light can you give us an idea
yeah i just tried to go with that that's
what was in the amendment that's it the
change in this okay and it does change
that and it's definitely a later date
thank you that's in line with what we
had been discussing
so with that we will jump over this bill
and we will go to the next cooperative
school bill which is 1679
relative to the dissolution and repeal
of cooperative school districts
this was a much uh larger bill
um so i'd like to call upon
representative cordelli for a motion
please
uh thank you mr chairman i would move
interim study
is there a second
i second
thank you very much representative
cordelli do you have any discussion on
the bill yes thank you
um as you might recall
the original bill
required
a
dissolution of all cooperative school
districts and a repeal of the statute
by mid-year 2025.
i passed out an amendment
that i'll just mention
that basically makes it optional
there would be a vote of the
cooperative school district if they
voted to
remain a cooperative school district
fine they can go on
within the district if they voted for
dissolution they would then
be able to follow the withdrawal process
um so it's a uh optional rather than
mandatory
uh but i i think some of the
same issues that uh representative
chairman ladd mentioned in terms of 1399
apply um here
um
and it
could
especially with the amendment uh take
more discussion and so that is the
reason for my interim study motion
is there further comment
from the committee
house bill 1679 relative to the
dissolution and repeal of cooperative
school districts the motion on the table
is interim study
representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield is yes
representative simon yes
representative
yes represent moffat yes represent
hobson
yes represent ford yes representative
sodie yes represent nelson yes there's
some luna yes from sam waltz
yes
represent
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd yes
okay so interim study passes 18 to 1.
okay good thank
you
okay two bills left
hb 1664 requiring certain non-public
schools
or education service providers that
accept public funds to perform
background checks on all employees and
volunteers
representative moffitt
thank you mr i'd like to move itl in
represent cordelli
i will second that motion thank you uh
representative do you care to speak to
your motion
famous you briefly uh
some concerns about some
possible unintended consequences with
some alternative education
uh
situations uh one example
in this came up a bit during the uh the
hearing
uh some alternative education situations
involve an apprentice-like situation
where in a trade
environment where
a student would be getting
whatever you name it whatever
special experience they wanted at a mill
or a
factory or
something like that
so with this to pass
there's a question about whether
anyone or everyone that the apprentice
type student or someone's getting a
trade experience
they may come in contact with a good
number of people at the
at the uh
trade venue or the factory or the mill
or whatever you want to call it so
because of some
possible unintended consequences and
questions about that that's why
thank you
representative cordelli
i believe there
there was an issue also in
section 3 lines 15 to 17
with the tax credit scholarship program
and someone
getting a tax credit scholarship and
taking advantage of home education
it seems to indicate that
i don't know i guess the parent in the
home would have to get a criminal
which i don't think is is going to
fly too well with most people and um for
that and
the reasons mentioned by representative
moffat
i agree with the motion
is there further discussion from the
committee representative luno
sure thanks very much i'm i'm actually
sort of stunned
that um that we're not
out to passing this 19 to nothing
um
unintended consequences of minors being
with adults
am i missing something here am i missing
something even following the governor's
state of the state speech last week
i don't know if members of this
committee are aware i certainly know
representative wallace is aware of what
the unintended consequences the
unintended consequences of minors being
with adults
are now presenting to the state of new
hampshire
and it's not insignificant
i i'm i'm
really taken back
really pain um to to try to think that
this is going to apply to parents of
home that are homeschooling their kids
um
but but certainly certainly should apply
to um to students that might be in uh be
in apprenticeship programs
with um these are kids
with with grown-ups with adults and i i
i'm
i can't believe we're going this route
representative mullin
yeah i don't know how we can take a a
chance on a situation where a child is
is alone particularly with an adult
for any instructional purposes
i mean we have been talking about
our uh sort of menu of educational
opportunities now for a couple of years
and it keeps coming up over and over and
over again that we need to do something
with the background checks
to make sure that the unintended
consequence isn't a child being harmed
so um
i would certainly like to reconsider
itlling this bill
further discussion representatives
i agree with all of this the problem is
as we know
we don't know how to do background
checks on some of these people excuse me
it's not as we know it's as you know in
your opinion
um it had to do with discussion we had
before this entire committee as given by
the safety officer
so i hope we know it since we all heard
it and sat here while he explained it to
us so i'm sorry as i know
and
some of the rest of us know
it is very difficult we don't have that
procedure yet for some people because it
has to be a government agency
that does the background check and if
you recall
and we've worked on this as you said
representative mullen for a long time we
have a bill in now
to figure out how to do this all through
the education
department it's not done yet we're still
working on it when it is done this bill
would be very appropriate because then
we would have a means and we could say
all these people need to go through the
doe and get their background check so i
don't have a problem with the principles
of this or anything it's just right now
i don't know how we would do it until we
get that other bill
worked out and then we will have a
method and then this will be very
straightforward and that's my only issue
and we've dealt with that issue for
going on four years now
and hopefully
we will get it done so that we can have
the guy on the construction site
know who he goes and gets a
and not the supervisor not the one but
the other guys on the construction site
go and get their background checks and
where and how to do it
and
at any rate thank you
thank you very much representative
excuse me my only concern is the
volunteers how to work around the term
volunteer
and that's my only concern but i agree
with a lot of points that both sides
have made
thank you represent tanner
thank you um yes we've been working on
this a long time and we've uh in statute
there's actually
some explanation about how to deal with
volunteers basically what we're looking
at
is when a person has
contact with a child where they're the
only person there
or if they're a volunteer if they're
there every week
working with the same child
um
we have
worked this is a this is again
representative lake it's a work in
progress it really is and we've we've
worked on school bus drivers uh we've
talked about substitute teachers in
multiple districts
um and
not having
not having a set
procedure in place right now
hasn't stopped everybody working on it
and getting a procedure in place
and it has very much pointed towards the
department of education
being the clearinghouse for this and i
think we can do parallel lines i don't
think it's one or the other i think we
do parallel lines because that puts
pressure on the department of education
to
work
diligently and quickly to get this in
place because we're talking about
uh you know aces we're talking about
adverse childhood experiences
that literally change the trajectory and
the life of these kids
um and we know that there's predators
out there
and we know that they
see
working with kids and working with kids
alone in different areas
are you know
prime
prime spots for them so uh and we also
know that a lot of the companies
um for example the construction guy
or the automotive technician
that their supervisor does background
checks but they don't do the chapter
five that the ones that we want
um they do you know they're worried that
that they're going to have uh
somebody there that's murdered somebody
or somebody there that's you know
uh robbed or
you know that sort of thing they they
don't necessarily um have the background
checks that hit the different areas that
we're concerned with so
i would suggest that we pass this um
and you know let's go forward with this
and and let's you know it's like you
said four years let's it's time and
we've missed kids
further discussion representative
woodcock
thank you chairmanland i'd like to just
to add to the the group from this side
uh i recognize register representative
nelson's concern about the volunteerism
but i'm sure it's going to be structured
expected bill as it is now for
volunteers in the school the same way i
mean that's how they do it i i do have i
understand also representatives is
concerned about the the background check
that the state program the next bill is
doing but that bill is a compilation of
all the
processes and all the all the uh keeping
them logged in versus the checking um so
that that sort of nullifies that but
regardless i do think representation is
correct if we pass this now which we
should then now just expedite the doe
working on that and completing that
activity for us
uh and then uh i do respond to
representative cordelli's interpretation
or home school programs or maybe rather
than muffin which one but this is the
programs that accept students so it's
not like a home schooler with mom and
dad this is a program where they have a
multiple youngsters in their house if
they have multiple youngsters in their
house they then have an adult with
minors and yes they should be
back on check there's this this almost
to me like the discrimination suit from
before this change is nothing this is
something very simple
thank you
represent woodcock yes sir um
does the state in this bill that
the provider
in the house has to have multiple
students or can they be their own
children
and if it's a person doing their own own
children do they have to have a criminal
background check or if does it state
that if there's other children coming in
from let's say the neighbor's house
do
do you now have to have a background
check well as i read this which is
different obviously representative
cordelli as i read this it says home
education programs that accept students
so that means i'm accepting students in
my program my children already they're
in the program just because i have 17
children that doesn't matter i have a
very happy family but those have less
children if we bring people in from the
neighborhood that's hard to explain
rather than what
so if i bring children in from the
neighbor's house i'm gonna have to have
a background check that's correct you
are now an adult in charge of a minor
101 or more than that however yes that's
a program you are now benefiting from
that like any other contractor which is
fine it's probably a great job in your
house i'm saying you should have a
background check not you particularly
okay i i got one other question for the
committee here
if in fact
does that online provider have to have a
background check when there does have
they have no physical contact with each
other now that is a great question
that's the best question today
really coming from another principle
wow we're elevating ourselves here we
know what happens on the internet
yeah yeah
answered it for me you know part of the
predatory uh
modus operandi of
people who are uh
going after children it's often through
the internet
um and that's where they groom them
until they can meet them so
uh i think that's uh definitely should
be covered in this
representative waltz and then represent
like us
just something real quick of an online
or a real life application and that is
my husband is a merit badge counselor
for the boy scouts of course i've had
their issues
and he cannot do
an online zoom meeting with the kids
trying to get the merit badge without
somebody else in the room so i often
just i'm sitting in the room so he has
another adult in the room but the boy
scouts are very strict about that that
even an online presence you have to have
another adult in the room
thank you
jefferson like us
a lot of the homeschool groups it's the
same way there's always two peop two
adults but i wanted to know if we could
have diana fenton come up so that i
if she's willing
chairman
why the uh general is coming up i think
freestyle today on our way up the on
line 24
it does it does um talk about in-person
instruction
so the video piece would be uh
in line five yeah both like in person in
person
right thank you now what what what lines
are you talking about there
five and 24 representative we're talking
about
uh the in-person instruction as we talk
about the video piece
so i don't i don't mean in prison i mean
physically present would be my
assumption but perhaps attorney can
representative leakers have the question
yeah um you've been through all of this
and met with the safety people
and everything we don't have the safety
guy with us today so i was hoping you
could answer this question
if
for instance we had somebody who's just
a homeschooler and they have a group of
parents who are homeschoolers
and one of the parents is meeting doing
chemistry say
how would they get a background check
who would they go to
i mean how would we comply with this law
so uh thank you for the question so my
understanding
of the regulations that govern the
department of safety and i have to say
as a caveat i do not represent the
department of safety i just
have worked in this area
very closely my understanding is that
anyone can access the new hampshire
record
you could
via their portal that they have now they
have an internet portal
you can look at anyone's record you
could go home and look at my record if
you'd like to and you're welcome to do
so
so you can get the new hampshire state
record for any purpose
when we shift our focus to the federal
fbi record which is the nationwide
database
um the regulations that pertain to
non-criminal justice purposes and that's
the term my understanding again with my
caveat still in place is that the
dissemination of the fbi record for
non-criminal justice purposes is as
limited to only governmental entities
so
based on that understanding
group of homeschool parents could access
that
that fbi record they can access the new
hampshire record
i could be wrong
i've been wrong before yes a lawyer's
been wrong before
um
but that is my understanding of how the
and will us pushing this bill
make you work any faster at the other
one
um
that to me is the best question of the
day uh will this make me work faster
um
here is so
this is a role as this committee is well
aware that the department is starting to
take on
the depart the department is starting to
take on this role of uh being a
clearinghouse house for criminal records
and the idea um
the impetus for this came from the
recognition that the department um prior
to the law passing was issuing
licenses credentials to people to teach
without running a criminal background
check
the criminal background check process
was part of their employment but that
still put the state agency issuing a
license to someone granting them that
authority without doing a background
check and as a state agency under the
leadership of commercial edible
we felt as a state agency that that was
simply inappropriate
to be
licensing people who might not be
employable under the section 5
violations so we have taken great steps
with the help of this legislative body
to pass laws to allow us to do that
and we are certainly in the process
of starting that process
and we are taking the steps to implement
the infrastructure by which we do that
because anything we take on such as
running background checks we have to
have the accompanying infrastructure to
do it and to do it successfully
i think that there is a significant
potential
for the department to take on these
additional roles
um and and i always hesitate to speak on
behalf of commissioner edelblut but i
feel comfortable saying that he would be
comfortable taking on those additional
roles
my caveat has always been and i've said
this to
my concern is that we have to have the
infrastructure in place and up and
running effectively
before we take on too much
and i say that in this area in
particular
because this deals with the safety of
children
and so while i agree with all the
comments that have been going back and
forth about the safety of children we
all agree with that
um my concern is simply if the
department is tasked with too much too
quickly uh
and something falls through the through
the cracks um
children will be harmed and and no one
in this room is okay with that
so while i think that potential is there
representative tanner and i have have
worked on this
quite a bit and we know the the bottom
line no matter where you come down on
the aisle is it is a complicated
issue
and so yes
the department has that potential i
think is a role the department is
willing to play um but again i would
request for whatever that's worth uh i
would request that we just simply have
the time to build that infrastructure
and
happily we'll report back to the
committee as to how that is but we just
had that law passed this past january
january 1st
and we have our rules in place and we're
working with our partners at the
department of safety
but there are
hurdles to to overcome to make sure that
that process can
further questions
yes representative mullen thank you mr
chair and thank you attorney fenton for
taking my question how long has the
state of new hampshire used the fbi
check as part of the background check
process
the state of new hampshire or the
department of education the department
of education
so again uh prior to last legislative
last legislative session
um the department did not do anything
with background checks before we issued
a a license or a credential to teach
whether it was state or federal
follow-up
so um were school districts
accessing the fbi background check or
they were able to access yes so pursuant
to 189 13 a
the law was set up that the background
check federal and state
representative woodcock
thank you chairman
uh transmitting thank you i have two
questions i'll put it on front so i'll
have to ask for permission um the first
one is
uh just a clarity uh on our
interpretation if we get your
interpretation of this line
where it says home education programs
that accept students
can you tell me what you think that
means and what line are you referring to
uh
yes
so uh i want to just add on one quick
item to representative mullins
question so representative mullen school
districts could receive the background
check federal and state because they are
a governmental entity so they fell
within that very broad bucket
to address your question representative
woodcock in terms of your interpretation
of the home education program that
accepts students benefiting from
scholarships grants or tax credits the
issue is
if i am teaching my own child
would i be subject to this that's a
question correct
well the question is if you are teaching
well the question actually is except
students that's the fortunate concern if
you accept students from
susan's house to come to my house to do
that
i think the way
it's written and it's again this is just
one lawyer granting their um giving
their interpretation
the way i read it common sense wise and
representative waltz you can certainly
weigh in um
when i read this
based on just on its face statutory
interpretation that i've certainly done
given its common meaning except students
my argument would be that falls outside
of your own
family
but
to be fair
could it be argued
that this applies to my own children
yes the way it is written there is a
valid argument to make that
thank you okay follow the second
question
thank you chairman
um and then in terms of time frames the
department's working on the
the the start of the thinking of
enlarging their infrastructure and
framework if this bill uh
was cleaned up based on what you're
talking about um
in the time frame for pat for uh act was
701 23
instead of 60 days from now
would that would that be would that be a
figure in your best getting i know you
can't commit for the commissioner or doe
but i'm asking is that a reasonable
amount of time for you do you think for
this bill
i i appreciate that question and i
appreciate the the generosity of the
time um yeah the reality is is this
the department um has a law in place by
which we have to get up to speed um and
yes i think giving us that
let's say year and a half
uh i think that is a fair
um
a fair amount of time for the department
to get that infrastructure in place
and i would appreciate that thank you
thank you chairman you're welcome and
while you're here uh diana um
what's the definition of volunteer
so the definition of volunteer in
rsa18913a
is
that
that term
is not defined in statute
that term is defined by each individual
school district so there is the term
volunteer and designated volunteer and i
use those uh terms in quotes
a designated volunteer
in general terms is someone who has
consistent access and opportunity to
have access with children
in a school district
each district defines those terms and
their own policy
and so you will see a wide variety of
definitions but by a general rule of
thumb
if i were to go into my my child's
school
to help with the
st patrick's day party
i would be a volunteer therefore not
subject to the background check
if however i were to volunteer on a
regular basis teaching
and i would have consistent constant
contact with children presumably
one-on-one then i would be a designated
volunteer and i would be subject to the
background check and the background
check would have the federal and the
state component to it
so whereas this bill says volunteer not
designated volunteer or vote you know
is there some confusion as to
what type of person we're dealing with
yes
not to add on to the words matter debate
but the terminology
the terminology is critical and what
we've seen time and time again
especially in education is the
terminology is sometimes not consistent
and when there is that inconsistency
then it causes problems later on and so
18913a uses the terms volunteer and
designated volunteer and those are given
deference to the the local districts to
define those as they see fit
um and so when we
look at this bill
using the term volunteer is there
possibility for confusion
and
inconsistent terminology
yes absolutely
are there further questions
representative tanner
thank you thank you for taking my
question are there other departments in
the state government
that actually handle
these types of criminal background
checks
like health and human services for child
care or
does the transportation department of
transportation
handle for
their group and i think
department of environmental s
maybe does camps somebody does camps
that's not under d.o.e but aren't there
a few
yes thank you for the question um
yes so
to the best of my knowledge the
department of health and human services
does oversee child care licensing
i don't know if that is for i think it
is for not only the entity
but also for individual providers i know
that that particular area falls outside
the purview of the department of
education
um the issue is to camps that was moved
recently from dhhs and i think it is you
are correct with environmental services
the other agency that popped into my
head during this during your question
was the office of public licensure
i'm not sure if they actively are
involved in doing the criminal
background checks i don't know if they
are but they work with groups
that do those so for example the nursing
board
the nursing board would would run a
background check before issuing a
license
to a nurse and oplc is a regulatory body
that oversees any complaints
so as a follow-up um so
there are procedures in in place people
in different departments have been doing
this for
quite a while right and and the
department of education actually
wasn't completely devoid of doing
background or getting involved with
background checks
in the spirit of at least training the
superintendents how to read the
background the criminal background
checks as they came in or when they were
getting a yes or no kind of thing
so as the law has changed
um
we have recognized that need to provide
trainings to the superintendents and so
i believe it was representative mullen
who successfully passed a bill last
session
to require the department of education
to do trainings for superintendents that
bill had come up previously to
representative mullen bringing it
forward and it was itled i believe um
it was not successful in its passage
and you are correct that the department
is playing a more active role in this
general area but i would
i would put forward that
doing a training on how to read a
background check
is very different
than receiving
hundreds if not thousands of background
checks and having to process those those
are two very separate entities
um and one of them requires significant
infrastructure for it to be successful
yeah i thoroughly appreciate that i just
felt as though your other statement kind
of sounded like we didn't do anything
with them but you did so
well you know i think anyone who knows
me
knows that this has been near and dear
to my heart for many years and when i
started at the department
i was very taken back taken up back at
the information that was being
uh provided to school districts to make
these important decisions pertaining to
who has access to children um
that was troubling and the department's
role in
issuing a credential
to an individual to teach without doing
the background check i found equally
troubling and everyone in this room can
agree with that concept so we have taken
a lot of active steps
to involve ourselves in this process and
you are absolutely correct about that
my hesitation to which that's what
you're picking up on is simply
recognizing that this is a new task
being given to the department
and we want to succeed at it and this
legislative body wants us to succeed in
it and to do so we need time to just
create that infrastructure to make sure
nothing's going to fall through the
cracks i don't like when state
government builds the plane as we're
flying it
and that's just based on my own
experience
go ahead um just thank you for all the
work that you've done on this issue
really
it is my pleasure and despite uh our uh
lack of success it was very fun to work
with you on that committee on criminal
criminal histories
just to wrap this thing up with you
diana
in terms of your
i cannot i cannot opine
as to this bill
to do so would be just to step outside
of my lane
we'll follow up on that yes go ahead so
um so
i guess the flip side of that then with
the programs that this bill applies to
where where there are no criminal
background checks being being provided
on on for adults who are working with
children are those programs ready
i i don't know if that statement of no
background checks are being provided to
adults i don't know if that is across
the board
accurate i think that this area is very
complex
and the ability to break this bill into
its its various parts to identify the
concerns of this legislative body is
a task worth undertaking
quick follow-up on that yes so would it
would it make sense then ms fenton to
maybe tap the brakes
on on some of these programs if um if in
fact the department cannot unequivocally
say that that
no
unintended consequences are going to
happen to children who are in the
presence of adults
well as i've testified previously
commercial edelblut and i have this
discussion anytime we roll out any of
these new programs so i can assure you
that that is always our top priority um
but when you look at what can be housed
with the department of education
and what is being asked of the service
provider
those are nuanced questions and those
are certainly worth debate by this
legislative body but if
if the
implication is that these programs are
rolled out with no thought to the safety
of children and the
implic implications of that that is not
an accurate statement and that is
something that each of these programs
has identified in various ways to
address
sure sure but but what would be an
accurate statement though is that the
programs get rolled out while the
department is still trying to figure out
what to do as far as compliance with or
as far as providing criminal background
checks and if
and if
a child's safety is
the primary concern
uh it seems at least from how the
department has has has been conducting
itself that rolling out the program is
the primary concern and that the
too i'm not sure if there was a question
perfect okay well good i didn't hear a
question mark um
i'm gonna stick with my prior testimony
uh
and
in all of our discussions um child
safety has always been the number one
priority
the role the department plays in that
i think has shifted dramatically over
the past five six seven years
and i think there's an enormous amount
of opportunity for what role the
department can play should play and will
play in the future
and i look forward to working with this
legislative body to enact that the
department's only request is that we are
cognizant of the fact that we are going
from the department plan zero role in
criminal background checks to taking on
a significant task
and while we stand ready and able to do
that we need the time and the resources
to do so successfully
that's the department's position okay i
got one last one for you here
sorry melissa
on lan line 19 it talks about
alternative programs for granting credit
leading toward
graduation
when we're approving these when the
department is approving
a program
that will lead to
credit
is there not a process which also vets
you know as we do every public school
to ensure that our
are the employees
are background checked
yes that's part of the rules yes that we
have absolutely and i think when i
testified previously on this i brought
up the
the rules for that particular program i
don't have them in front of me right i
understand yes i understand that thank
you
representative woodcock
chairman just just to be clear for me um
so on that last question chairman ladd
the rules that under the uh alternative
program you folks just discussing the
rules are full background checks for
state police that type of piece
or it's just a partial doe review
i would have to look at those rules but
i know that
a requirement for
background checks pursuant to 18913a
because that is always our standard
that is to the best of my understanding
incorporated within the rules
thank you thank you thank you very much
are there any further questions of uh
tourney fenton
you got your fourth star today
thank you well uh representative ford
said i should ask that what be in
writing not just verbal so
[Laughter]
thank you very much
okay we're back to discussion as a
committee here is there any further
discussion on this representative mullen
yeah my question is whether or not um
we have a motion is the motion itl
my question is whether or not we're
delivering the wrong message by
indicating that this is an inexpedient
to legislate
piece of legislation without considering
interim study and just at least keeping
it on the burner
as a priority area
for not only this committee but also for
the department of ed i and i'm open to
that suggestion um there's
we all want to have children safe
but you know i in looking this initially
my first was overlooked at 60 days
getting this done can't do that
looking at some of the terminology that
i couldn't explain
but i think after this discussion it'd
be wise that we would draw the itl
motion and put forth an interim study
that would be my suggestion but the
makers the motion would be the ones to
have to pull that back
who made that motion mr chair you
wouldn't be putting words in my mouth
would you uh
you made it mike
uh as a maker of motion i i uh
given reps and moans comments and also
attorney fenton's uh i would withdraw
the itl motion in favor of an is motion
if i could get a second
yeah who made the second
gun
i can care okay so the motion's off the
table
so you withdrew it right
that's correct okay so
represent would you like to make a
motion please
uh no no no yes sir i i make the motion
for interim study thank you very much
is there a second to the interim emotion
reps
represent hops and you made the motion
thank you
so we have a motion on the table for
interim study made by represent mullen
and second by reps and hobson for
interim study to this bill
1664.
further discussion
sure oh no no just just just real quick
um um we we were
um representative tanner and i were
knocking around this idea for a little
bit as well
and um and uh i personally i feel very
strongly about
that we should um move forward with an
ought to pass
and if there are little tweaks or i mean
or or put this off and bring back an
amendment to push the um push the
effective date out 90 days
um or push it out till
to
july 1st
that could certainly be done
i think the other material parts in the
bill i think are very strong and and put
child safety first
um but that all said
um uh i'll i'll support the um the
interim study
uh
uh so that we can um because we're
i'll support the interim study just
because i think an itl is just a
terrible um
uh
disposition for this uh for this bill
further discussion
not singing madam clerk would you please
call the roll
yes thank you
this is regarding
house bill
1664 requiring certain non-public
schools or education service providers
that accept public funds to perform
background checks on all employees and
volunteers the motion on the table is
interim study
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative simon yes
representative blakis yes represent
moffett
yes from hobson yes represent ford yes
representative soti yes represent nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz
president cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
allison yes
i'm sam mullen yes representative
woodcock yes roxanna muse yes
representative hall yes and chairman
ladd yes
so interim study 19 to 0. thank you
consent okay
okay
uh yeah 1594 relative to assistance to
certain students with disabilities and
i'd like to open this up the discussion
first before we
we have a motion made on that
and why i'm doing this is that
there are some strengths in this and
there's also some issues and i'd like to
bring them forward
i see section one or
there's one a new section then you have
roman one and roman two within
i'm having some problems with roman 2
where if you comply with this
then you
and if you offer assistance to
all kids in the school
then
you're not going to have to necessarily
go through with
it
we heard that there were a number of
schools that are probably doing this
right now i don't know if they're doing
it in their iep but i know they're doing
it and registering or getting kids
familiar with how to register
in the social studies programs
in the schools some are doing it some
are not
so i just like to open it up right now
for a little bit more discussion on this
bill because you know there's some
things in it which are not bad yes
represent cornell
i think in testimony we heard that it
was a standard discussion in iep when
they're doing transition
when a student on an iep is is at that
age
it's it's standard
iep language to to talk with them and
about voting
so i i think
it happens
is it sop standard operating procedure
for
a kid that has
any kind of an iep or is for those that
are having
i think would be any high school
not this one
i think it would be any any student
whose iep has a transition
program in it
not all ieps have transition good
programs
doesn't say that in this bill represent
cornell
a transition i plan program or a plan
chairman
yeah
relative to that question i think on
line 14 maybe the answer
um
because it talks about the youngsters
with ieps as long as they offered
appropriate assistance by the school
which would be what we've been asking
and
so
line 13 says students with disabilities
are going to be get the assistance they
need
go ahead reps i'm on
thank you representative vlad um
so when i read this
section one uh asks for
some very specific actions to be taken
and that is that when the iep team
convenes
so that would be all of the people that
are knowledgeable about the student the
students parents and the student
that when that iep team convenes at the
time between the age of 17 and turning
that they shall excuse me shall discuss
whether or not voter registration is
appropriate
and if so when and how it's going to be
accomplished
and that a goal
and you know iep goals are specific
entities that a goal actually be written
into the iep it also references uh
students
who have section 504 plans as well
and i think that that is an important
feature because uh
a lot of time kids who have 504 plans
that don't have
a case manager that is dedicated to a
small number of students sometimes it
it's the school counselor that has
75 kids on 504 plans i mean i think that
the idea that all kids who are in
special service programs are indicated
here is really quite important to this
bill
i also
many of you know that in a previous
iteration of myself
that i ran uh the special olympics
program in the town of bedford so i
dealt with
a ton
of young adults who were transitioning
between high school
graduation and the workforce
and one of the classic complaints of
these young adults and their families
was that sometimes people underestimate
the talents the strengths the
understanding and knowledge that our
disabled young adults have and i think
that
making them part of their
civic privilege and responsibility of
voting
is one of the most critical things that
we can do
for this age group
representative i i agree with you um
where i'm concerned is that in in the
first part we're addressing those
youngsters
that need to have a transition plan as
you've said
written right into the iep and that is
more specific
help than i see in section two if you
have somebody coming in several times
during the course of the year
and working with all students right then
that will suffice i don't think that
does suffice for the i would agree i
would agree with you wholeheartedly
in this bill then i think that we're
mixing kind of like apples and oranges
with the two areas there i would much
prefer and would support a bill that had
section one alone
and then leave it up to the social
studies teacher in the administration
and locally decide whether we're going
to bring them in and i hope you do bring
somebody in to help with teaching kids
that voting is your constitutional right
and this is how you do it
but i i could support this it was
amended to leave that second part out
and and and stay with part one yeah if i
had to make a guess i would say that
that was put in
as sort of a
nice nice consideration for schools that
are already doing some things but
i i section one i think is gold that's
the guts gold yeah
yeah
so if the committee is supportive of
where i'm coming from i'd like to delay
any action on this bill until we can get
an amendment which deals representative
if you would
that addresses section one
and i do not see
if that if we have some concurrence on
that
rick i think that's yeah we're good with
what you just suggested okay good thank
you dave thank you
so with that um that concludes the
executive sessions for today
and get ready for a freight load of
bills tomorrow
and uh we started what nine o'clock on
this nice chair
nine o'clock right here same place same
station
and go home think positive things for
the ukraine please
yeah yeah yeah
how do you feel about that
all right
it's a transitional plan that's for the
heavy-duty kit
that
you